Based upon the test results, it's it's inconsistent with striking
an arm. My conclusions was to be one of the arguments the defense
is making is that the cops basically broke the tail light and
spread it themselves. Owlet record by Edward Snowden, which she
had brought and explained that our cell phones are traceable
and things of that nature. Okay. Okay.
He dropped me in the in the forest and he dropped me off and
he tracked me.
Um they're basically apparently on all counts except one, the
jury said not guilty in the first trial. And because they didn't
write that down because they just thought they thought they had
to have a unanimous thing on all of the counts, right? So they
didn't write down not guilty on a bunch of the accounts and we
hung on one. They just hung on all of them. So now she's being
retrieded on all of them. Or at least I think that's until they
if they get a bad verdict here, I think they might appeal on
that. But so the the prosecution's case is that the guy never
made it into the party that Karen Reed backed up into him as
he was going into the house, hit him and killed him. And uh the
other side is saying no, he went into the party, they him somehow
in there and then they threw him on the front yard and then they
framed Karen Reed for it. That which included when they went
and got her vehicle, they broke her tail light and spread it
all over. Got it. They tried to show that it was like evidence.
Okay, we're go through two videos like this and then we're going
to go on to closing statements. Then eventually maybe some stuff
around actual early deliberations. Okay, guys. So, we're on to
Karen Reed trial stuff. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
Let's go. Sure. Removed from the diddy case. Okay. Hold on. Um
I'll maybe take a look at this later. We're not on the Diddy
case right now. We're on the Karen Reed case, but we will maybe
look into that at some point. So, thanks for being here and participating.
Dark Panda Ozel. Good night. Have a good night, buddy. Hope you
enjoyed the stream so far. We'll talk to you later. All right.
Karen Reed, murder retrial. best moments from the Commonwealth.
So, the prosecution, we're going to watch their best moments
of the trial. You will learn that on January 29th
of 2022. I think this is from the first day when this guy's mic
was totally
this guy, you couldn't hear this guy at all. When the defendant
and Mr. O'Ref were in front of 34 Fairview Road, you will learn
that Mr. O'Keefe got out of the car and he stood by the side
of the road after an argument with the defendant.
She clipped John O'Keefe,
fell backwards,
hit his head, broke his skull, and she simply drove away. Karen
Reed is not guilty of hitting John O'Keefe with her SUV.
There was It's up that the defense's bike is so much better through
a lot of this. No collision. Has been a few of
you. Oh, Tenstone five gifted. Let's go. Thank you very much,
Tenstone. Appreciate it, buddy. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Biased and corrupted investigations. Never about the
truth, folks. It was about preserving loyalty. Did you receive
a phone call? Yes. From Carrie Carrie Roberts. She said um John
was found in a snowbank. They don't know what happened. And at
some point you ran over to where Miss Reed was. Yes. EMTs were
around and they were working on the body. She was running around
um and saying, "Did I hit him? Did I hit him? Is he dead? Is
he dead?" There was a woman
next to us who told her to calm down. Direct examination. Canton
Fire Department paramedic. Stop talking. Calm down. You're hysterical.
So she repeated, "I hit him." And a police officer asked her
said, "You what?" And she repeated it again. I hit him at some
point. Who were you? I can't wait to watch cross on that person
because again, if you guys remember the big question you should
totally have when you hear the paramedics or anybody else say,
"Oh, you heard Karen Reed hit this guy. Why didn't you write
it down? Why why did you not let anybody know? Why was that only
reported days after the initial investigation? Days after the
body was found? Why did nobody remember that detail that day?
What the Stop talking. Calm down. You're
So she repeated, "I hit him." And a police officer asked her,
said, "You what?" And she repeated it again, "I hit him." At
some point, were you with the defendant when she spoke to an
officer and a first responder? Um, yes. She told the first responder,
"I hit him. I hit him. I hit him." Was it important to you before
you testify
to tell these jurors under oath that my client said I hit him
three times? As a juror, I mean as a witness, it's important.
Oh yeah, I forgot. Also, Cherry, I don't know how much of this
you've watched, but yes, heavy Boston accents here. Okay. As
a juror, as a juror, to tell the truth and to answer the question
you are trash asked. And in point of fact,
In your entire grand jury testimony,
you never said, "My client said the words, I hit him."
Again, it's 227 pages. Made, you were there. They're your words.
I'm not asking you to rehearse something. You were there. Did
you tell the grand jurors that my client said I hit him? I have
testified a number of times, but I was there the morning of January
29th when your client said, "I hit him. I hit him. I hit him."
The defendant stated that she dropped Mr. O'Keefe off at 34 Fair
View. She did not see him go in the house. She was asked about
the damage to her rear tail light. Uh to which she stated, quote,
"I don't know how I did it last night." She stated that she made
a three-point turn and left. When you came out of Meadows, did
you have a chance to look at the defendant's tail light on her
Lexus? Yes. Karen pointed out and said, "Look, my tail light."
And I said, she said, "Do you think I hit him?" Do you recognize
that item? Yes. Is that one of the items you bagged that night?
Yes. That night, do you recall if there was any other pieces
of tail light recovered? I believe in total we located maybe
six or seven pieces of tail light. What type of work uh were
you assigned to do in this case? Uh so I was given items of plastic
for comparison. The red plastic
um that I sampled from item um from the debris from the clothing
was found to be consistent
channel points for baston cherry in color
microscopic appearance. I think that could just be cherry ASMR.
Okay. and instrumental properties
with the
what did she say? What what was the word she used that I mocked?
I can't even remember the word she used that I just mocked. I
actually don't remember.
Jer
jara. This is what I told the jeras. Jer
the jar from the plastic from the tail light. So there's some
expert forensic witness saying it was plastic from the tail light.
Plastic from the tail light. Now, taillights from the car where
all of the CCTV
that should have been picking up that car driving home that morning,
okay, and seen the broken taillight. All of that CCTV footage
corrupted conspicuously
only at the moments when Karen Reed's vehicle was going by. Somehow,
somehow this happened. He didn't look mortally wounded as far
as I could see, but could I have done something that knocked
him out and and in his in drunkenness and in the cold didn't
come to again? And this would have been the moment you would
dropped him off.
Yeah. What would have happened to him? He was the body was completely
covered, but his head
was completely covered. So I started to dig around his face and
his eyes and um his left eye was fine, but his right eye looked
like it was huge. Um like he had had something happen to it.
There were um a series of
cuts and bruises
to the right arm. There was also a bruise on that same arm on
the back of the hand. Did you come to a conclusion about the
How are these even highlight? Sorry for the prosecution. How
are these even highlights? I don't get it. Cause of Mr. O'Keefe's
death. The cause was blocking pack injuries of head and hypothermia
and the manner was undetermined. John O'Keefe's cell phone evidence.
What was the total snow accumulation from the storm in its entirety?
23.8. 8 in. So just short of 2 ft. Is that correct? That's correct.
The ground was frozen. The soil was frozen. That's insane. That
is an insane amount of sand. And the surface of the ground was
frozen. Um and it would have made the ground impenetrable. Why
did you go back to the spot where John was lying when you first
saw it? When they lifted him up, there was grass underneath him
and I could see his phone. At 31 minutes and 56 seconds, we start
the health event that shows 36 steps were taken. The message
pull behind me is red. 32 minutes and 9 seconds. Uh the messages
application is uh closed uh and the device is locked for the
last time at 1253. That's about what 21 minutes or so after that
phone stops moving. What's the temperature? 61 FH. You mentioned
that you were looking for time information or power on power
on information regarding two events. Correct. Can we characterize
those events as text stream events? Yes, we can. That second
text stream event is a backing up maneuver. When you looked at
the time from the Lexus clock regarding that backing event, did
you do an analysis of John O'Keefe's phone? Yes, I did. when
you apply that variance between Alexa and
we got uh Spruce asked if No, you have to Okay, maybe Cherry
can say it. I don't know if Cherry will say that. Sound good.
Wait, why didn't Tape's thing in bed? That's weird. Tape should
be able to post stuff.
Hey, Mr. O'Keefe's phone. The time of that tape doesn't have
his thing between 12:304 and 12:30. Tape probably as
bad. Tape keeps his thing. Don't take tape rolls away. and business
administration offered at the University of Alabama. Correct.
Correct. That should be bachelor of general studies with minor
in mathematics and business administration.
And what you just articulated you do not possess that you sit
here today. Correct. That is correct. This will be the day before
this incident.
You'll hear that cast
at 12:3708 a.m. The defendant calls John and voicemail number
one is left. 12:594 a.m. the defendant calls John. Voicemail
number three is left. John, I'm telling you is nobody knows what
the wrong pervert. Do you know if there's any jealousy in that
relationship? Karen wouldn't let I mean they did everything together
a lot of things together and I thought at times yeah you could
see you know she didn't want the girl women around John the niece
of the victim officer John O'Keefe she took the stand today she
was softspoken as she talked about the breakdown in the relationship
then they went into details about the possible motive and that
aruba trip. She said that there was a lot more tension and fighting.
And then she went on to describe the fact that her uncle, who
again she called JJ, asked Karen Reed to leave his home after
that trip, that New Year's trip, and Karen Reed refused to. The
totality of, you know, to put a label on the whole thing. My
opinion is that she's trying to get revenge. Get revenge. Yes.
Gave revenge on John. Yeah. For what happened in on New Year's
Eve? Yes. Wow. So, that's the highlights for the prosecution.
Lots of that didn't even make sense to me as like highlights
for the prosecution. Son is bad. Assan is bad. Boom. Okay. I
didn't I don't actually so I know a little bit about the trial,
but some of that stuff didn't even make sense to me. Like the
scratches on the arm shouldn't be a highlight for the prosecution
at all. But maybe it's just like highlights from their questioning.
They call it Commonwealth. All I know is that I felt like watching
these highlight clips would help once we go to the closing arguments
so we can kind of like remember who we saw say what. Yeah. Yeah.
Karen Reed is not guilty of hitting John O'Keefe with her SUV.
I know this guy loves this guy believes that comedy and effective
statements comes in threes. Okay, so everything he says when
he wants to emphasize, he will triple that. Okay, she is not
guilty. She is not guilty. She is not guilty.
There was no collision. We performed a a uh drop test with a
hybrid 3. So that's an instrumented uh anthropomorphic test device.
Another word or another phrase often used in association with
ATD
devices are crash death dummies. Correct. Correct. Yes. Why did
you utilize 24 mph for this test? There is a a triggering event.
The speed is approximately 24 mph. So we did a test at the the
end point if you will in that data set. Were you able to reach
any opinions or conclusions as to whether the damage to the subject
tail light is consistent with striking an arm at 24
It based upon the test results, it's it's inconsistent with striking
an arm. My conclusions was respect to the So, one of the arguments,
one of the arguments the defense is making is that the cops basically
broke the tail light and spread it themselves and there's no
way they covered the jacket with the holes in it. Not yet, Top
Roa. But we just got on to the defense's highlights. So, this
is them saying, "No, no, no. It's pretty inconsistent with the
like them hitting a a human in the arm." Like, that doesn't seem
like you could have getting that gotten that kind of breakage
on the light. The abrasions are that it was inconsistent with
contact to the the tail light. Uh, and that not only that those
injuries are inconsistent, but you would expect
additional injuries, likely fractures to the the hand and or
the forearm depending on the actual speed of the vehicle.
do any of the tech stream events or do any of the data that you
uh Soap box. Thank you for the gifted sub. Appreciate it, buddy.
Appreciate it. Don't know why the audio is up on that, but thank
you. Thank you. You've reviewed either yourself through Mr. Burgess's
report through Dr. Welch's report. Do any of the data indicate
that there was a collision on January 29th, 2022 at any time?
Neither of the events that occurred on that date were triggered
by a collision.
So that guy seems to be saying that you couldn't get John O'Keefe
dead in any way from that kind of collision at that speed. 24
miles an hour. You couldn't get him to like kick. That seems
weird though. You'd expect some of the other injuries to make
sense. You had to bet who do you think is winning this? I think
Karen Reed's getting not guilty on all charges. If I had to guess,
I that's from what I'd seen to the evidence. That seems like
the most likely thing to me.
a call. Defense lawyer looks so worried about the jury's ability
to be able to determine that Alan Jackson's a performer though.
Okay. And his name's explain why the after this. Can you explain
like what happened with this and why it's at a retrial?
I can explain it right now. They came back and the jury was hung.
Um they're basically apparently on all counts except one, the
jury said not guilty in the first trial and because they didn't
write that down because they just thought they thought they had
to have a unanimous thing on all of the counts, right? So they
didn't write down not guilty on a bunch of the accounts and we
hung on one, they just hung on all of them. So now she's being
retrieded on all of them or at least I think that's until they
if they get a bad verdict here, I think they might appeal on
that. But oh my god, wait. So then it makes so much sense that
this defense lawyer is like, "Bro, can we stupid proof this?
I need you to stupid proof this." That actually is a good argument.
Yes. Is we already we literally had a hung jury once. Please
do not around. That's actually totally fair. Yeah. Yeah. That
might be exactly why he's so concerned. From the troopers assigned
to the Northwalk District County um DA's office in regards to
a vehicle that was in a at a residence in the town of Dyen. At
the time that Michael Proctor called you, did he say anything
about what his intentions were once he arrived at the location?
Yes. His intention was to uh retrieve a vehicle that he said
was involved in a homicide. Sergeant Baros,
is this the condition of the right rear tail light when you showed
up at the re household at around 3:15
in the afternoon on January 29th, 2022? Absolutely not. So, this
area was intact. This is what I saw was missing. Did you tell
those law enforcement agents on August 9th, 2023? Wait, hold
on. Who was this guy? Wait, I didn't I didn't see this guy's
name. I was just listening. He is the Dyton Police Department.
Direct examination of this guy, Sergeant Nicholas Barrows. Cuz
basically the the argument from the defense is, yeah, that the
cops basically broke the tail light themselves. Is this the condition
of the right rear tail light when you showed up at the reed household
at around 3 3:15?
What's up? When you say the cops broke this tail light, you're
talking about the cops that he was at the party with, not the
cops who arrive at the scene of like the crime, right? No, the
cops the cops who like because because the people who own the
house were themselves cops. Uh what the conspiracy is is that
basically the guy went into the party. So, the the prosecution's
case is that the guy never made it into the party, that Karen
Reed backed up into him as he was going into the house, hit him,
and killed him. And uh the other side is saying, "No, he went
into the party. They him somehow in there, and then they threw
him on the front yard, and then they framed Karen Reed for it."
That which included when they went and got her vehicle, they
broke her tail light and spread it all over. They tried to show
that it was like evidence.
Yeah. Okay, I'm getting it now. Yeah. January 29th, 2022. Absolutely
not. So, this area was intact. This Oh, sure. And they can't
bring this up now in this trial, Cherry. But in the first trial,
the prosecution quote unquote accidentally mirrored a video and
then argued that like the they weren't even on the side of the
broken tail light when it was sitting in uh like basically they
said, "Okay, here's a video. It shows that that tail light couldn't
have been messed with while it was in our custody."
But they mirrored the video. Bring that up. They're not allowed
to bring it up because they mirrored the video. So obviously
it seems duplicitous like it seems uh like they're lying when
they mirrored the video. They say we can't touch touch this tail
light and you find out oh no they mirrored the video and actually
there's a cop standing by that tail light precisely when it could
have been broken and like been used to plant evidence.
So they but they presented as like evidence of their own and
then people realized that it was mirrored like text and stuff
was mirrored on the screen and they're like oh no you're actually
that doesn't that doesn't absolve you at all. You're just being
crazy. Uh Bergusal, thank you for the 9 months.
Hold on. Where is that? Nine months on kick. Thank you very much.
Appreciate it, dude. Yeah. So, but now because that was misfiled
or something. Now it's like a new trial and they just are going
to file the correct video and they can't bring up that the previous
trial had the evidence broken.
Yeah. This is what I saw was missing. Did you tell those law
enforcement agents on August 9th, 2023
that you uh Sophia, we might do that talk. I don't know what
the talk's like. So, if it was like all good, maybe maybe u if
you're doing a Reddit post and you have time stamps though, I'll
probably cover that tomorrow. Perfect. I think we saw Brian Higgins
and Chief Burkowitz go into the Sally Port together and alone
with the SUV
for a wildly long time.
That was my recollection at the time. Do you want to be here
today? Now, I am put on the stand in a murder trial. I don't
know why I'm here. I have no connection to this case. You mentioned
that somebody had suggested we talk burger. Yes.
One of the male members of the defense team. They were looking
for me to say that I saw Higgins and Burkowitz in the garage
with the car.
You showed them that.
Yes. How did they respond?
They became very aggressive, raised their voices. And the one
word that I can very definitely remember is they said that they
would charge me with perjury. John went over to Karen and he
gave her I'll be honest. I was doing some stuff in the background
there while we watched that clip. Was she saying that the the
cops like threatened her to not testify correctly? Is that why
is that what that was? Who said they threatened her with perjury?
It would have been the cops, right? Or a kiss on the forehead.
It just stood out to me. I was like, "Wow, that's the sweetest
thing I've ever seen." Did you have any concerns about Karen
being able to drive that night? I had talked to her all night
and I did not notice anything strange yet. Like I didn't think
anything of it. That wraps up our look at the defense case. Let's
bring in our panel to see what they think about this time around
for the defense. We have criminal defense attorney and former
prosecutor Frs Borcart with us, domestic violence expert and
former Didn't this guy just shoot some people in Minnesota? No.
Whoever that is. Why he got the cosplay like Twitch
e-girl
thing in the background? I'm sorry. This I I'm sorry. I'm seeing
it. I'm see I'm seeing it. I It seems similar. Does he look like
that guy?
It's not exact. It's certainly not exact. Okay. But it feels
not that far away. It feels not that far away somehow. Now the
hair is way different. Hair is way different. Sorry. This guy.
Are you saying this guy's got the e-girl stuff or this? Oh, no.
No. No. the the changing thing, right? Yeah. I think Kelly is
one of those. Yeah. If you're a cosplayer,
I think Kelly has one. Woman with a webcam. You got that. And
I think Pisco, too. Okay. Former law enforcement officer Claudia
King. That's Pisco farms those big donos with that. Okay. He
goes behind there and he starts taking his clothes off. That
the That's for the big donos. And investigative journalist, author,
and podcaster M. William Phelps is with us. Let's talk strongest.
and not necessarily strongest evidence because this is a defense.
They don't have to prove anything. But what are some of the strongest
points? No, you don't think so. You don't want to you don't want
to hear just like real quick the um like what they're what these
people are informed. I think I think it would be good. Now, there
would be better people on YouTube, but it's five minutes strongest
and not necessarily strongest evidence because this is a defense.
They don't have to prove anything, but what are some of the strongest
points for reasonable doubt you think the defense did bring this
time around? William, I'm gonna start with you. Uh, hold on.
That the person said that the tail light wasn't even broken that
way. That it was broken after that when he pulled up to the party.
It wasn't broken that way. What What else is there? There's um
there's got to be something around the dog bites, right? The
dog bites seem so up. So, he had these like scratches and bruises
on his arm, Cherry. And they look like scratches from a dog basically.
And And these people had the snow or the ice.
I have no idea. But with the with the dog, okay, they these people
got rid of their dog right after this. They like rehomed their
dog. They had their dog for like years and they like immediately
rehomed their dog. This guy had like all these big scratches
on his arm and [__] And they said it's like oh from
hitting the ground, but it's like all uniform scratches along
his arm and they just got rid of their dog. They get rid of the
dog so they can't get the um the teeth analysis bite mark. Yeah,
because then that would prove that it went into the house. Oh,
they also sold the house that had been in their family for like
a couple generations or something. They sold their house and
moved. Very innocent behavior. Oh, they also Yes, true. Tenstone.
They had pig DNA in the wounds as well. They found pig DNA like
from a pig's ear or something like something you'd let a dog
chew on or treats. It's all crazy. It's very Start with me. I
don't know. I'm a little biased here, you know, because I think
they're charlatans. I think they're slimy. I think uh they've
done I'm grabbing a drink real quick. I'll be right back. I'm
listening. Nothing but hurt people in this case, attack witnesses,
and create a conspiracy that is just nonsense. Oh, that being
said, you know, Allan Jackson talking about a cancer that has
a name, Proctor, um, in his opening and then not calling the
guy, I think says a lot to the jury, right? Um, if there is some
reasonable doubt created by the defense, you know, I think it's
a totality of the witnesses that they put on. But if I'm a juror,
I'm going back and I'm going to look at these witnesses. And
a lot of these witnesses, if we're being honest, were very hostile,
right? Um um I'm thinking of just yesterday um uh a doctor uh
from Is the FBI gonna investigate this someday? What are the
odds? Uh I think there were some feds on this case, right? I'm
pretty sure there were feds like investigating corruption around
these police departments like while this case was going on. Is
that that's not the guy who got fired, is it? Was he a fed? He
wasn't a fed, was he? It would be internal affairs, right? Maybe
there was something going on. This guy up here, this Brian Higgins
guy, I think was a fed for some reason. I can't remember the
spiderweb of relations here. Anyway, the doctor from ARC, you
know, very hostile, you know, wishing his kid happy birthday.
I mean, I mean, pausing. What? Why is there a video of Aaron
Reed bending over?
Why is that something they had to include?
Weird pause, by the way. But don't know. But Jello ninj
is me up right now. Yeah. He said, "I missed the whole story.
Any motive why the cops would have killed him?" Yes, I think
Jay- Sock knows the gossip. Something about somebody wanting
to sleep with his wife might have gotten into a fight. Yeah,
the the Higgins guy, the Higgins guy wanted to his wife. For
sure. For sure. For sure. That's one of the police the the guy
who died. Was he a police officer, too? Yes. They're all cops.
Yeah. Right. So, they were all at like this house party together
because grown men, police officers, they still party like frat
boys apparently. They do. So, that's basically what's happening.
They're trying to imply like, "Oh, this guy actually never went
to the party. He never made it. The wife must have uh reversed
on to him and killed him. That's what happened. That's what happened.
He wasn't We never saw him." And lo and behold, we're It just
seems like the cops themselves like something happened. This
guy died. Whether one of them him or accident happened. Either
way, they're just like covering it up. Actually pinning it on
the wife. Insane. Yeah. Girlfriend technically, but yes,
There's a dog bite specialist that came in and went over all
the bites in his arm. Oh, I didn't know that, but hopefully that's
in the closing arguments. I'd like to see it. This trial I I've
looked at hundreds of murder trials. I've Is it that the dog
would be biting the dead body? Well, it would show that he went
in the house, right? The dog wouldn't have been outside like
those. You would have been able to say, "Oh, he got scratched
while he was alive or something
and or like but while he Yeah, basically while he was alive based
on, you know, how the skin like torrent that's like animal behavior,
right? That you die and a pet will like eat your face or something."
Yeah. But I think it's I mean the argument I would expect is
that a dog would basically if there was a fight, a dog might
have jumped and like scratched somebody up or try to bite somebody
if it was going after an owner of the house. Yeah. Yep. Yeah.
Yeah. Jog, will you be in a subathon in the future? I don't know,
Ruben. Ruben, why do you ask? Sat
for it. We're actually technically in a subathon at all times.
Did you know that one aerodyite woof, please? Uh, you could donate
for that. That's really weird to just request. Um, also, no,
you're not going to get it for money, weirdo. Uh, you might.
I mean, there's definitely an amount of money where I would hit
that button, but
how much for Aerodite? Woof. Okay. Uh, I think you could set
that up on Streamlabs, can't you? Just be like five, 10, 15,
20 bucks.
I should just make it like a $20 donation thing. I think you
should just stop because that person is like desperate to act
like she's being
against her will.
Yeah, that's true. Uh, J, did you watch Higgins and the Defense
do dramatic reading of the text with Karen Reed? Nope. Nope,
I didn't watch almost any of it. We didn't watch very much of
the trial, unfortunately. I think we just had other stuff going
on, but tonight's a good night to catch up, guys. It's a great
night to catch up. In courtrooms all over this country, I've
never seen anything get this far, you know. Um, so is there reasonable
doubt? There could be. Um, but I think that the jury is smarter
than that. I will agree with you that this case is a unique one
that it is unlike really any trial that we have covered here
on Court TV. Wrong. Reasonable doubt. What's the strongest point
that the defense has this time around? So, I'm going to play
defense attorney here. Um, I think in part the strongest reasonable
doubt is I don't think the Commonwealth has necessarily proved
murder. Um, and that's a problem. I don't know that they proved
that she had specific intent to anyone. So, I start there. Number
two is I think the the strongest piece of evidence for the defense
is the the the because of Trooper Proctor, it it chisels away
at the reliability of any of the Commonwealth's evidence. And
when you start chiseling away at the reliability, we're not talking
about planning evidence. We're talking about, for example, are
the are the shards of glass on John O'Keefe reliably there? because
she hit him with a vehicle or because they weren't properly handled.
These are issues for the Commonwealth. They can't get around
it. And and by not calling Michael Proctor, he becomes the unseen
monster that is a boogeyman. So, I I think I I agree it's a totality
of circumstances defense issue. Now, that being said, nobody's
going to like that I say this from the Karen Reed uh uh uh guild.
Here's the It's I'm surprised all of all of these people seem
to be saying there's not really reasonable doubt here. I don't
think so. I thought the last I looked into this, Karen Reed was
gonna go free. Why are these guys saying no? No. They pretty
much do. They have her hitting him on camera. No. Um I No, no,
no. Maui is a totally different thing. But I don't know why.
Oh, yeah. His background is weird, dude. Another person with
a squid in the background. He's got a He's got like a Yeah,
octopus. Yeah. Whatever this is, this looks like an octopus drawn
by his kid. He must He must love or something, I think. Which
one's Jesus? This one. There's like a statue to the left of his
head.
This one that's like Mary. Wouldn't it be Mary? Isn't that a
common Mary post? I don't know. I think so. No, I don't got statues
of these people. He's got like a He's got like a I I can't tell
if this is an angel or a Warhammer character. Okay. Do people
normally put
Do people normally put their Christian their Christian stuff
next to their hight? I don't think so. Just uniquely this guy.
This guy's got some weird [__] going on. Cherry.
Very weird. Okay. And he's he thinks that the police are innocent.
It seems to be the case. I'm surprised I'm seeing like Karen
Reed is going to win this. Sorry, is going to lose this. I It's
very surprising to me. The thing for Karen Reed, if she gets
convicted of a lesser charge, like a lower charge in the defense
world, that's actually a win when she's facing murder. So, I
do think that there is alternatively to a not guilty argument.
I think that there's a strong argument for ladies and gentlemen
of the jury. Even if you if you if you think she did hit him,
she didn't mean to. And if if she didn't mean to, she didn't
want to, then it's something less than the top. So, I think that
that is a subargument for the defense. I don't know that they're
going to make that argument, but I think that there is a possibility
of compromise in the jury room during deliberations. You know,
we're talking a world of difference in sentences between secondderee
murder and manslaughter in this case, though it does have the
enhancement of drinking and driving. Claudia King, look at it
from the defense side. What do you think is going to be something
the jurors may use to say, "hm, I'm not sure about the prosecution's
case." I think there's a couple things. The first one I would
point to would be the manner of death. The fact that the medical
examiner could not conclusively say, you know, yes, he was hit
by a car, this was an accident, or this was a homicide. So, I
think the jury may say, well, if if she can't even say that,
how are we able to say that? Uh, and then I also think Dr. Wrenchler
did a good job um and also presenting the X-rays. So to me it
is hard to to say, "Wow, he if he got hit by the car and and
did all that spinning around that we saw the test dummy do, how
were there no fractures, breaks in that arm." So I think those
are some of the best pieces that the jury could look at potentially
for a not guilty or as Fron said um a lesser conviction. Sure,
we are all going to be standing by. I think those are all great
points. I thought that Sergeant Barrow's testimony that the tail
light looked different when it doesn't seem like he'd have a
reason to lie and probably every reason to say something different
and more consistent with the Commonwealth, but for him to come
in as a defense witness and suggest that something may have been
changed after that vehicle was seized, I think that speaks volumes,
and that could be a major problem for the Commonwealth. Wow.
Okay.
All right. On to closing statements from today. Oh, shocking.
Ran Paul thinks the US should not help Israel. I He's never taken
that position before. That's a crazy crazy thing for Rand Paul
to say. All right, defenses closing arguments. Starting here,
1737,
we have Alan Jackson giving the closing arguments. Okay, this
was 3 days ago. Let's uh let's go. Let's go. There was no collision.
There was no collision. That's not Rand Paul. Wait, no. Rand
Paul was in the previous video. He's right here. Yeah, that No,
Rand Paul is not the defense attorney. That's Rand Paul right
there.
There was no collision. I want to take a minute. Did you just
do it three times? Wait, that also sounds Oh, I just got like
deja vu. But for Trump when they say there was no collusion.
There was no collusion. There was no like Russian collusion.
He should have He should have said it three times. Everybody
would have believed him.
Put his hands together like a curve like Trump. Hold on. I got
to click this. This just popped up for me. Emergency broadcast.
Kyle Kolinsky. Trump says everyone should immediately evacuate
Tyrron. I just wanted to see if he was in his car again at the
golf course, but he's not this if you want. Five five minutes.
All right, guys. I have some terrifying breaking news here for
Trump just tweeted the following. Backstreet Boy news. Let's
go.
Iran should have signed the deal I told them to sign. What a
shame and waste of human life. Simply stated, Iran cannot have
a nuclear weapon. I said it over and over again. Everyone should
immediately evacuate Thrron. Everyone should immed
The best the best thing is every single news network is now carrying
this is USA orders evacuation of Tyrron
and everybody's fleeing Tyrron. He's just he doesn't realize
that he's like got the power to actually make other countries
empty their capital out. He was just saying it as I feel like
a turn of phrase like you're gonna get up and and actually people
just started leaving Tyrron.
Like the highways are all jammed getting out of Thrron.
It's wild. 10 million people that live there. And here he said
casually, "By the way, it's 2 a.m. in Thran right now. It's 2:00
in the morning." He said everyone should immediately evacuate
Thran.
What the are you threatening?
What are you threatening? It's so crazy that he didn't even just
say flee Tyran. He's like the the loss of human life is so tragic.
Nothing. The US hadn't done anything yet. He's just like the
loss of human life is tragic. Tyrron should be fled. Okay, get
the out of there. Dude, what are you doing? All of these all
of these I think uh like re aerial refuelers are coming over
to the Mediterranean. All right. From America. Not. The first
thing that popped into my mind and the first thing that probably
popped into your mind when you read this is is he talking about
nuking tan? Like is he gonna greenlight a nuclear attack on tan?
Like we actually have to have that conversation now because of
what he said here. What if what if it's like the opposite? Okay,
just hear me out. Hear me out. What if he is snitching and this
is his way of sending an SOS? Like, oh, everybody's going to
think I'm just unhinged on the toilet. It's fine. But honestly,
get the [__] out, guys. Get the [__]
out. I don't Israel's [__] drastic. Yeah, I can't
do anything. These people own me. Get out.
I I don't know why he just went to nukes. I don't think anybody
was thinking nukes at all.
I It's the bleach that he puts in his hair. Yeah, I guess so.
Michael Tracy called this perhaps the most reckless statement
ever made by a US president in history. This guy Oh, reactable.
Okay, reactable. I'm really sorry since you're a new follower
here, okay? But you just said this guy's a Yesterday the fuel
supplies were attacked in Iran, which is a sign of a ground invasion.
How going to ground invade Iran?
You would have to ground invade Iraq first. You have nowhere
to go into Iran over the ground. That's not happening. Iran's
one of the most difficult places to invade on planet Earth. That
would be crazy. Well, hold on. Hold on. What are we doing here?
What's up? because they are a new follower. I would just like
to make it clear reactable. That might have been a really dumb
point, but this guy might also be. So, yes, 50% right.
As King Morg Morgot just said, not for a nuke. Yeah, but that's
not a ground invasion. This guy just said a ground invasion.
What kind of ground invasion starts with a nuclear weapon? Excuse
me. I need everybody on the same page here. Those are not the
same thing.
Yes, Iran is literally like it's it's literally surrounded by
mountains. It's so hard to get into that country. You would It's
crazy.
What are we doing here? And by the way, uh when he says Iran
can't have a nuclear weapon. Well, congratulations. They don't
have a nuclear weapon. They weren't trying to get a nuclear weapon.
They were following the peace agreement, the nuclear peace agreement
that we made with them that was put into place by Obama. They
were following it perfectly and you ripped it up in 2018. You
destroyed that. That's true. True. And by the way, once you pull
out of the deal, although I have no idea if they were actually
following it perfectly. Something tells me Iran was probably
pushing towards a nuclear weapon anyway, just at a slower pace.
Then you're in no position to turn around and start lecturing
them about their nuclear program. If you wanted them to not create
a nuke, well, you should have stayed in the deal that was working,
which was preventing them from getting a nuke. So they had every
right to enrich to whatever point they wanted to once you pulled
out of the deal, once you violated the deal. But by the way,
they were not doing that. So this is so beyond reckless. This
is I mean look I don't know what's going to happen but just the
fact that the first thing that pops to mind for everybody is
like every Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Blackpill. So they wouldn't be able
to do it overtly and they wouldn't be able to to divert significant
resources towards it. But if they if they didn't have something
going on in secret somewhere I would be so shocked like like
they almost would have to just in a way that's so small scale
that it can't be tracked. Right. Like wait a second is he talking
about nuking tan? Is that what he's talking about? And if it's
not nuking, what is it? Is it some sort of like massive attack
in the heart of Thran which could like tens of thousands of people
probably like
I'm I am flabbergasted, man. Every time you think it can't get
worse, it gets worse. And by the way, all of the idiots on the
right, all the MAGA idiots who are pretending like, "Oh yeah,
I'm against war with Iran, but Trump was duped into this and
it's the people around him who are forcing him to do it." And
he actually in his heart is really for PE. Does that sound like
this for peace? Does that sound like he's for peace? Everyone
should immediately evacuate Thran. And by the way, the deal that
he was saying they need to sign is a deal that would have prevented
them from enriching uranium even for just power for their power
grid and for scientific research. As Crystal pointed out, that
was called that's what's called a poison pill in the deal, giving
them terms, you know, they could never agree to because why?
Because Netanyahu has always wanted this war. Wait, does Iran
rely on a significant amount of nuclear energy? How much wait
how much nuclear energy does Iran use? Uh
what would you even Google for this? Iranian power grid energy
in Iran nuclear but with nuclear and renewable sources contributing
only 1% each. Yeah, that's what I would have thought. What the
Also,
why the why the are they um why aren't they using any solar power?
Aren't they in a good location for solar power?
Everyone relies on nuclear. Yeah, but they're barely using nuclear
energy.
Despite the heavy reliance on fossil fuels, Iran has a significant
potential for renewable energy due to its geographical location
near the equator. 90% of the country's land is suitable for solar
power generation for at least 300 days. Yeah. Why aren't they
doing any of that? What the what? And Donald Trump was more than
willing to assist him and greenlight it and let it happen. And
the next phase is going to be the US even more directly involved.
We're already involved. We're already arming it. We're already
funding it. already helping uh with some of the defenses on the
ground, the air defenses, but it's only going to escalate further
now. But again, what a chilling statement that is. I mean, this
is disturbing.
Everyone should immediately evacuate Thran.
I mean, I don't have anything insightful to say here other than
holy, this is this is a really disturbing, really chilling moment
because like e either that's a threat of a nuke or some massive
attack, but even if it's even if nothing happens, it's still
like terrorizing a city of over 10. Could you imagine a scenario
where Iran
said
he's making me feel bad for soying about it? Cuz it is a totally
tweet.
Yeah. Just don't say it's a nuke. It's like Yeah. He's saying
Israel's going to [__] you up or we're going to help
Israel you up and you guys should flee to Iran.
The leader of Iran, the Grand Ayatollah said evacuate New York
City immediately or evacuate Washington DC immediately. What
would What is the weird curl behind his left ear? Are you talking
about his earrings? He's got multiple earrings that he wears
most of the time. He wears like a loop earring and a stud.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And he has arm [__]
He does have like tribal tattoos on his arms. Yes. This guy literally
went to like the the mid1 1990s, early 1990s. It was like, I
Yeah, I do want to look like just like the standard I don't know,
like frat guy from this time. That's like what he wanted. That's
like when he turned 40, he was like, this is who I want to be,
a 1990s frat guy 100%. Oh my god, man. Oh, not even a half year
into Trump's second term. Not even a half a year into this regime
and we already have I mean I've aged probably
tribals were 08 to 10. Okay. Well 7 years in this 5 6 months.
So I I don't know how the [__] we get through this
bro. This is just I mean what the everyone should immediately
evacuate Thran. I mean shame on everybody who hasn't jumped off
this bandwagon yet. This is a straight up fascist terrorist ass
regime and it is there's no plausible deniability left. I mean,
that is so wildly disturbing. Fact check that person. There's
no way he's 40. Shut the [__] up. Kyle Kolinsky.
Oh, he's definitely He's like 38, 39 at least. No. No chance.
Why? Why would you think I'm lying? Okay. 37. He's 37. 37.
37. Yeah. Oh, he's also got some good tweets that come out. Okay.
Iraq is WMDs. Iran's WMDs. Hey, I've seen this one. They're trying
to get you guys into a war. Stop.
Okay, that was our quick stop off for
Cocholinsky Town. Okay, but Oh, but hear me out. But this time,
it's actually true. And all of these people are like, "Oh, this
is the boy who cried wolf." No, don't do it. Don't do it.
Oh my god, he's got his tattoo in the background for his show.
That is like his tattoo. I'm almost positive. Also, if it's trip,
if it's that would suck if it was the one time the uh
in this case it would be like the
I don't want to say it. It sounds racist, but the Drew Jew crying
wolf like hey they said they said is they said Iraq they said
Saddam had WMDs. They better not be lying about Iran. Ron doesn't
have WMDs. They just have 80% of WMDs. Okay. Okay. I think we
are good with Mr. Kolinsky for today. We're back to restart this
dude. Yes. Where are we at? Right here. Right there. There was
no collision. There was no collision. There was no collision.
There was no collision. There was no collision. There was no
collision. I'm sold. I want to take a minute. And then they declared
Karen Reed innocent on all charges. Not sorry. Not guilty. Not
They don't declare somebody innocent. They say not guilty.
Not guilty.
To start off with thanking you.
I want to thank you for your attention. I want to thank you for
your patience. I want to thank you for your diligence. This is
not an easy undertaking. Thank you. Thank you. First of all,
I want to thank you for your courage because courage is what
this moment this moment demands. Not just to listen, but to stare
directly
at injustice and say not here, not now, not on our watch.
That's what you're being asked to do. Stare down in I want to
start with the simple truth. You folks, not us, nobody else in
the courtroom. You folks are the last line of defense, the last
line of defense between an innocent woman and a system that has
tried to break her, that falsely accused her, that tried mightily,
mightily to bury the truth. This case was corrupted from the
start. It was corrupted by biases and conflicts and personal
loyalties that you heard about. And most fatally, it was corrupted
by a lead investigator whose misconduct infected every single
part of this case from the top to the bottom. In our opening
comments to you a few weeks ago, we told you what to watch for.
We warned you what to watch for. We begged you what to watch
for. Watch for the physical evidence. Pay attention to the medical
facts. Pay attention to the science and the physics. But also
pay attention to the integrity, the very essence, the integrity.
Is that the jury? He's addressing the jury. Oh, it's the guy
who doesn't have a mouth. Remember him? He appears to have a
mouth now. No mouth. When we talked about this guy who like often
looks like he doesn't have a mouth at all of the investigation
his like his lips are like the exact same color as the rest of
his skin. So you can't really see a differentiation between his
like but you also saw something during the course of the trial
that none of us might have expected. Something that should sadden
us something that maybe would anger us on full display. You saw
the lengths to which some some police officers will go to to
protect their own at the expense of the rest of us at the expense
of Karen Reed an innocent woman. Before we examine the evidence
in the case, which we will do, we need to understand the very
foundation of the entire system of justice in which we operate.
That sounds like it could take a while. I don't know. I I'm on
a schedule here, buddy.
No. Explain the three branches of government. Do it.
Guys, uh we are one Sorry. We are two subs away from another
hour on the stream. We need you guys to dig deep. Okay guys,
you like the content, you can donate. You can add more time to
the stream. We are two subs away from another hour on the stream
right now. We can do it. You can do it. I believe in you. Okay,
two subs or $10 via Kickbot or Streamlabs. Okay, exclamation
point. Donate in the chat. Maybe the other Maybe the other streambot
is back. There it is. Oh my god. Kickbot TTS is there, guys.
We are $10 away. Two subs. Let's go. The bedrock on which this
entire system is built. reasonable doubt. This isn't just a technicality
and it's not a slogan. It's a constitutional shield that protects
the innocent. It prevents the government from punishing without
Quinn Clay. Thank you for the gifted sub. I appreciate it, dude.
Thank you. Thank you. Proof. And underscored. Thank you for the
gifted sub. Let's go. 1 hour 23 minutes
on the clock. Boom. Boom. Boom. There it is. There it is. There
it is.
Thank you guys very much. Appreciate you. And I'm going to reset
that timer. And there we go. We're good to go. The Commonwealth
has the high burden to prove every single element of every single
charge beyond a reasonable doubt and to a moral certainty. As
I said, those powerful words are not just some legal jargon.
They're your mandate. They're your obligation.
They're your community's protect. Dude, too many gifters, not
enough. Can she act like she wants to be found innocent? What
is that? Has she ever heard that like if you smiled, people would
like you more? Karen, you stupid [__] No, no, no,
not that. I'm just saying it smells. It smells It looks like
somebody farted around her or something. It smells like somebody
farted around her. It looks like she smells a fart. Damn. Damn.
Damn. Damn.
It wouldn't hurt to smile.
Would it smile? Would it to smile? Anonymous. Thank for the gifted
sub. I can't see who did that. Almost certainly it will be it
will be outed through the sub in two seconds. Five. Four. What
is she looking at? It looks like she looking at somebody who
owe her money.
Damn. Did they fix it? They It doesn't out anonymous subs anymore.
Oh my god. They presumed innocent cloaked in the presumption
of innocence. That presumption is not fragile. It doesn't just
disappear because there's a charge or a badge or a theory. That
presumption stands firm unless and until the Commonwealth clears
that high bar, the highest bar the law provides proof beyond
a reasonable doubt and to a moral certainty. That means at the
end of this case, at the end of the trial, you think about one
or more of the charges. You think, you know what, maybe maybe
that's true. It might be true. Then you vote not guilty. If you
think it's possibly true or probably true, your vote must be
not guilty. If someone among you thinks it's likely true or even
very likely to be true, your vote is not guilty. It's because
none of those standards maybe, might be, possibly, probably likely,
very likely. None of those meets the Is that AOC? I That is one
thing we've heard quite a bit that Karen Reed in fact looks like
the Aryan AOC, the blonde AOC.
Um, many people are saying extraordinary burden of beyond a reasonable
doubt. Many people are saying to a moral certainty. A moral certainty
means a level of confidence so strong, so incredibly unshakable
that you could go home, you would go home, look your loved ones
in the eye, and say, "I am certain."
Not probably, not likely. I'm morally certain, and my certainty
remains unshakable. The law defines moral certainty as the highest
level of certainty known in all human affairs. Think about that.
You must be that certain about the entirety, not part of, the
entirety of the Commonwealth's case. As we discuss this case,
you'll see that the Commonwealth comes nowhere near nowhere close.
For a second, I thought this was 3 hours and 38 minutes of just
Allen Jackson's final statements or whatever his closing, but
it's both. Thank God. Holy to reaching that extreme burden of
proof. Ladies and gentlemen, on January 28th, 2022, it was a
Friday night. John O'Keefe and Karen Reed made plans to meet
up with friends, go out for drinks. You saw through video evidence
and eyewitnesses that they were affectionate, they were loving,
uh they were in good spirits throughout that evening. They started
off at CF McCarthy's, which you've heard about, eventually made
their way over to the Waterfall Bar and Grill. When they got
there, the Albert family, they were already there and they were
already drinking. The Albert family, it's been established as
a very well-known family in Canton. They've got quite the reputation.
Brian Albert was at the waterfall, a longtime Boston police officer.
His wife, Nicole Albert, was there. She was with him. His brother
Chris Albert, who was a Canton board selectman, he was there.
His wife, Julie Albert, their daughter, Caitlyn, and his sister-in-law,
Jennifer McCabe. whom you met and her husband Matthew McCabe
whom you did not meet. They were all there drinking before John
and before Karen ever arrived. But also present at the waterfall
that night was Brian Albert's friend Brian Higgins.
We know that he had a romantic design on Karen. That becomes
an incredibly important fact as we discuss the fact of the case.
As the bar was closing around midnight, the Alberts invited everybody
back to their house. They wanted to keep the the night going.
But the evidence reveals something interesting. That the invitation
to John O'Keefe appears to have been for a different reason,
an alternate reason. Think about the video of Brian Higgins and
what Michael Proctor in his investigation.
Okay, so uh fun fact, I don't know if they brought it up in the
highlights we watched, Sherry, but there is video from one of
the um from one of the bars that shows I think is it Brian Higgins
who has to be held back from going after John O'Keefe? Like literally
one of his buddies like actually holds him back from like yelling
at him and going after him. Oh, like they had words. The same
night previously. The same night. No, the same night.
Yeah, the same night. Completely and utterly ignored. Higgins
was agitated after a day of drinking. Agitated that it was John
and not Karen. Jon with Karen, not him. Recall that ominous text
that he sent to Karen with her and Jon standing just feet away.
I mean, I guess if you want to paint a narrative, you could you
could do this. Well, isn't that ominous and terrifying, Cherry?
Absolutely, dude. I can't imagine being in a bar with some girl
who you like had flirty text with and you see her with her boyfriend
and they're having like a good time. You like you make eye contact
with her and then you text her. Um well um well um
uh well well
weird. He got weirdo dude. And then we see this.
That's what Brian Higgins was confronted with following his um
well text.
What of all things starts going through Brian Higgins's mind.
Where does his mind go? What is he thinking about after seeing
this? After witnessing this, he shows you. And if Michael Proctor
had been the least bit interested, this video would have shown
him, too. Take a look. See it. Um well, these are like 50-year-old
men, by the way.
A pause. Hello.
I think you're supposed to get a rude,
Fighting techniques. Where was Brian Higgins mind? What was he
thinking about? And then what happens before you look at the
next video? Think about what you're going to see. This next video
is after he sees John kiss Karen on the forehead. After he send
Yes. Oh, this is the video. Text to Karen with her standing just
away. Watch closely and this is what you're going to see. This
is what Michael Proctor and his investigation completely ignored.
Higgins
Oh, whoops. is very clearly upset. He's agitated.
Chris Albert tries to control him, tries to talk to him, calm
him down. I moved my headphones and apparently they're like vibrating
between being out of my ear and you thought about not forcefully
grabs Higgins along. You'll see that in the video that you're
about to watch. It appeared that Chris is trying to calm him
down from something. Brian Albert standing right there with the
other two men, but Brian Higgins is having none of it. He appears
to be hyperfocused on one person and one person only, John O'Keefe.
In an instance, Higgins angrily jerked his arm away from Chris.
Higgins rugs his brow and he directly gestures at John. A gesture
that looks a lot like, "Let's step outside. Let's go outside."
But John looks at him, takes a quick beer, completely ignores
him. Let's take a look. Take a look. Let's check it out. They're
going out of the bar over here. That's him. That's him. And let's
go. Let's go. Let's go, bro. Let's go. Let's go. Wait, what are
you hype manning right now? Michael Proctor, the lead investigator
in this case. Wait, do you not see this guy doing it? That he's
like he's pointing over here. This is like at John O'Keefe. They're
saying like he's literally pointing at John O'Keeffe and going,
"Let's go outside."
Oh. Oh, okay. Okay. Look, he's like saying, "Hey, you. Let's
go outside. Let's go. Come on. Let's go." Oh, take it outside,
bro. Let's go. I I get it now. Michael Proctor, the lead investigator
in this case, had all this footage, but he did nothing. He had
access to the exact same thing that you saw. Why did he do nothing?
Corruption. Few minutes later, please. Higgins then texts John
directly.
You coming here?
Three question marks. Oh, wait. What? Higgins texted him directly?
It's now 12:20 a.m. These guys are not good friends. They barely
spoke or even acknowledged each other when they walked into the
bar together, other than a quick greeting. So, why was Higgins
coaxing John over to 34 Fairview? you coming here after this?
And why not text Karen? Because at that moment, he wasn't interested
in Karen. He was interested in John O'Keefe.
This is about 5 minutes before John gets out of the SUV and walk
toward the house. About 5 minutes before Karen sees him alive
for the last time. So, what happened inside that house or that
basement or that garage? What evidence was there for the investigators
to look into? What did they ignore? Laceration over John's right
eyelid. Black eyes. A large dog at the home. An obvious dog bite
on John O'Keefe's right arm. A head injury from falling backward
onto a hard surface. Alleged surface. A text from Higgins. One
of the last people to ever communicate with John O'Keefe. You
come in here. Those words now echo in the wake of John's death.
But Michael Proctor, he didn't listen. When John didn't come
back outside, Karen, very oblivious to what had happened, thinking
she was just left alone in the car out in the cold in the middle
of the night, she got frustrated and she drove home. She arrived
back at home and her Wi-Fi connected to John's, sorry, her car,
her phone connected to John's Wi-Fi at 12:36 a.m. It's an important
time. 12:36 a.m. She left John voicemail after voicemail after
voicemail. He was unresponsive. He didn't pick up a single call.
He didn't respond to a single text. Dude behind him, born from
crazy. Why would you The longer he didn't respond, the more upset
she got. Her voicemails reflect that frustration after the fact.
That's the frustration that you hear in her angry voicemails.
She uses harsh words and foul language. She's obviously upset.
She's obviously irritated because he didn't come back out of
the house and he wasn't responding. Wrong though. But Karen did
not know what you know. She didn't know what the investigator
should have known. This guy or he didn't know what was happening
with Higgins and Albert with her boyfriend John O'Keefe.
To me sounds like right twice.
Uh possibly. I feel like you're you're saying you could be convinced
for either of them. I can be convinced on either one. Yeah, 100%.
Looking for him in a panic. As you know, her worst fear realized
when she found Jon beaten, battered, bloody, and left in the
snow in Brian Albert's front lawn. At 6 a.m. when Karen found
Jon, you heard about the scene. It was described in detail. It
was chaos. To use Mr. Brennan word in his opening statement,
it was bedum. The screams for help by Karen. The yelling and
the hollering, ambulances, emergency lights, fire engines, ladder
trucks, paramedics, patrol vehicles, patrol officers, all of
them swarming all over the lawn just under Brian Albert's bedroom
window. And of course, as you learned during the course of this
trial, Brian Albert, a sworn peace officer, a first responder
trained in being a first responder. Never came out of the house.
Never went outside to help a fallen fellow officer who was laying
on his own property. Never came out. And you learned through
the undisputed evidence. Okay. You guys think uh got it here
that he's wearing a realistic silicone mask? It is. It is. He
is. Spruce. Thank you for the 14 months that the lead investigator
Michael Proctor
on like a ring camera. I I realize how realistic it really is.
It's so realistic into the house. The Commonwealth has struggled
to try to prove that John O'Keefe ended up in Brian Albert's
front lawn because he was struck by a vehicle. They have failed.
They cannot and they will not ever be able to prove that John
was struck by a vehicle beyond a reasonable doubt and to a moral
certainty because the science does not lie. The medical evidence
does not lie. The physics do not lie. Their investigation was
flawed from the start because their investigator was corrupted
from the start by bias personal loyalties. Folks, they cannot
prove a collision. John O'Keefe was not hit by a car. There was
no collision. So, let's start there. I want to take a minute
to discuss the actual science, the actual physics, and the actual
medical evidence that was presented in this case. The science,
it's an old saying, is known as the silent witness. It doesn't
lie. It doesn't forget. And notably, it doesn't take time. If
there was no collision, what are we doing here? In order for
there to be a collision, there has to have been an impact site.
The vehicle had to struck John. Period. I want to remind you
of some of the important testimony in the entire case, and it
comes from the Commonwealth's own facts. Don't care about yours
science. I think that means that Steven Jillian's had a couple
drinks tonight or Okay, seems to be seems to be the case. Yeah,
I don't know. Medical expert, Dr. Reini Sport, the Commonwealth,
Saturday. Do whatever you want.
It's Monday. Medical examiner, someone governed by law to make
these decisions. What the [__] you doing drinking
on a Monday? We know that a person struck by a vehicle suffers
massive trauma. Broken bones, fractures, soft tissue damage,
torn ligaments, contusion, soft tissue injury, severe tissue
injury, crushing blows. None of that was spread with John. None
of it. Not anywhere on his body, including his right arm. Not
one bruise. Nothing. The fact is the injuries are not from a
vehicle impact, not his head injury, not those scratch and bite
wounds. Not a single medical expert, think about this. Not a
single medical expert called by the defense or called by the
Commonwealth has testified that Jon was hit by a car. Not one.
Think about the irony. Not one. That's not just significant.
It's literally the most important point in the entire trial.
Listen again to Dr. Sporty Bellow's words. Question. I'd like
I beat that into the ground, right? Not a single time or not
a single person that they brought up on on the stand is willing
to say I stake my professional reputation that this guy got hit
by a car. Zero but you put this woman in prison. You're going
to you're going to charge her with murder. How?
You did not include in your autopsy in any fashion any discussion
of whether Mr. O'Keefe's injury were consistent with a motor
vehicle accident. Did you answer? No, I did not.
She told you, quote, "I did not see any evidence of an impact
site." End quote. She was talking about John's body. The Commonwealth's
own medical examiner, Dr. Scordelloo, performed the autopsy.
She did it personally. She's the only one to have personally
examined John's body, and soon found no evidence of an impact
site on his entire body. That in and of itself is reasonable
doubt. You don't need anything more. The Commonwealth case is
done. It's cooked. Their own experts said there is no evidence
of a of a collision. No evidence of an impact.
If you want to know what an impact looked like, take a look at
this. This is what a body looks like after being struck by a
car at 25 miles an hour. And this is what a car looks like after
hitting a person at 25 miles an hour. Now, they're not showing
on screen, but I guarantee you it's gross. And I'm eating, so
I appreciate them not showing it. These are exhibits from Dr.
Welchure, the Commonwealth expert. John didn't even have a bruise.
Make no mistake, Dr. Sporty Bella was presented with the Commonwealth
theory of the case, the same case that you've been presented
with, and she refused to conclude that John's death was a homicide.
She flatly refused to to conclude that there was a collision.
And you know who agreed with that? That silent witness. The science,
the physics, the data. Dr. Wolf and Dr. Winsler, you just met
them recently. They explained they were not initially hired by
the defense. They were asked by another agency to conduct their
analysis. They looked at the evidence from both sides. Not taking
aside for the defense or the Commonwealth. Completely independent.
They looked at the damage to the SUV on one side of the coin.
They looked at the injuries to John O'Keefe on the other side
of the coin. Both PhDs, both engineers, determined there was
no collision. I'm not saying it. The science says it. That SUV's
tail light was not damaged by striking an arm. And John was not
struck by a 6,000lb SUV. Period. Full stop. Dr. Dan Wolf did
the testing on the tail light. Actual testing, not some ridiculous
blue paint kindergarten project. He did lab testing. He did field
testing. He did data testing. Actual impact for analyses. In
every single test at every single speed, the tail light damage
was inconsistent with striking an arm. In every test, the tail
light damage was inconsistent with damaging the shirt, the sweatshirt.
Remember that severe internal damage to Karen Lee Reed's tail
light, not just the outer lens. The internal diffusers were completely
smashed, completely shattered. Archite testing established that
all the internal components of every single tail light, especially
the diffusers, remained completely intact. Conversely, on Karen's
tail light, the diffusers were almost completely gone. This is
basically saying from this kind of impact, you would not expect
the damage from hitting a body to the tail light that we saw
in this case. Like something else happens weird. Folks, understand
something. If any part of that diffuser, any part of that diffuser
portion of the tail light is broken, there is no light. It doesn't
illuminate at all. It's just black. Let's take a look at a couple
of photos. At 5:07 a.m. at One Meadows, that's the photograph
on the left. What do you notice about the red tail light? It's
completely illuminated. Later at 4:12 in the afternoon, photograph
on the right. It's lit up. How can that be? How can that be?
If the Commonwealth claimed that those diffusers, the portion
that lights up the light, we're already scattered all over 34
Fairview. That's their theory.
But don't believe your lion eyes. The tail lights completely
lit up. That would be impossible. Dr. Dr. Andrew Wrenchler, a
PhD, a biomechanist, explained that at those speeds, the other
side of that coin, John's arm would be basically destroyed. Contusion,
swelling, torn ligaments, hyperextensions, dislocation of joint
and bones, fractured, broken, and shattered. But as you know,
John's arm was pristine. Save those dog and claw bites. He didn't
even have a bruise.
Think about
I don't What, bro? Are we all pretending the pot aful Nathan
interview didn't happen? I don't know what you're talking about,
Felder Rami. But
I don't if this is all true, if he's not just lying right now,
which I assume people could say, "Hey, you're not you're making
things up. Like, you're just lying."
I How is she being found guilty if all of this is true? This
is wild. This think about that photo of those x-rays as you deliberate.
You can manipulate a tail light fragment. That's not that hard.
You can't manipulate a bruise. If they claimed the car was going
fast enough to shatter the tail light and shatter the diffusers,
that it was also going fast enough to destroy and shatter John's
arm. And it simply did not. How do they square that? They don't
and they can't. So they spent nearly $400,000 in taxpayer money
to hire someone to dress up and look like John and paint an arm
blue, which told you exactly nothing. The architect conversely
also established that it is impossible for John's sweatshirt
sleeve to be damaged by an impact with the tail light. The Commonwealth
theories that the sleeve of John's hoodie sweatshirt was damaged
by flying shards of tail light slicing through the shirt and
through Jon's arm. I have three questions. Number one, John's
arm had 36 abrasions. How did 36 shards of acrylic go through
nine tiny little puncture holes? How'd that happen? Somebody
needs to answer that. Number two, why are there no slices or
cuts in the hoodie? All the defects are punctures. Punctures
that you might get from, say, I don't know, K9 teeth. And number
three, if the shards cut bloody gouges into John's arm. That's
their theory. Why is there no blood, no skin, no tissue on a
single shard of taillight that they claim came in contact with
John's arm? The Commonwealth cannot answer a single one of those
questions because Blond's arm was not impacted by the tail light.
It doesn't make sense. Uh, Felter Nami, we don't talk about like
children um and their like internet escapades on this stream.
All right, you want to follow children, you should go follow
like some teenager. I think um
probably you should talk to but you go talk about kids somewhere
else simply because it didn't. Let's let's not compare contract
the arc expert
to Jud Welchure. He came to you in the Commonwealth case and
chief and he told you that for the better part of a half a million
bucks, he'd come in and testify that John would haul enough to
touch the tail light with his elbow. That's it.
And even in that basic demonstration, he had to lean in to manipulate
it to get the result that he wanted. Dr. Welch then claimed the
reason he didn't do the reconstruction, the actual testing. Think
about what he said. There isn't enough evidence to determine
what happened. I I beg your pardon. What happens when there isn't
enough evidence? In his words, not guilty. You vote not guilty.
That's what happens.
not mine. The Commonwealth also used the same company, Aperture,
to try to establish a time of a collision that never occurred.
The Commonwealth called Shannon Burgess, the supposed expert
from Aperture. There is a cardinal sin for expert, folks. A cardinal
sin. It's called confirmation bias. If when you decide to change
your opinion to fit a theory, the most important takeaway from
Shannon Burg's testimony was how brazen, how shameless he was
in trying to change the data to try to suit the Commonwealth.
Remember Mr. Burgess, I'm sorry, remember Mr. Brennan's opening
statement. He made some promises to you. He said, "This case
is about the data." He stressed it over and over again. They've
had three and a half years to get this right. The Commonwealth
has had this case for three and a half years to get it right.
So his top expert, Dr. Welch, prepares a report and that report
says that John O'Keefe was struck by Karen Reed's SUV at 123138.
Note that time 123138
38. Okay. He was struck. He was immediately incapacitated. He
was immediately unconscious. So says Jud Welchure and the Commonwealth
theory. But there was a huge huge problem with that. And somewhere
in the middle of trial, something
that's going to be that his cell phone was mo moving after 123138,
right? His cell phone data, he had location data turned on that
was moving after 123138. Show me that as an answer, Mr. Jackson,
I can realize that the very data they produced unequivocally
establishes that they are wrong about a collision. It could not
have happened. Why? Because John was interacting with his phone
after 12:3138.
Remember the collision immediately incapacitating. How could
he be interacting with his phone afterward? He was on his phone,
opening his phone, checking his phone, reading texts on his phone,
and locking his phone. All of it after 12:3138,
which is the time Welchure clocked for the moment of the impact,
and he was taking steps and walking with that phone after 12.
How the [__] How the are How is he so much better
than the people who were on that that video? We watched watched
a video with like three apparent lawyers who were like, "No,
there's not really any reasonable doubt here at all. I don't
know how I'd work this as a defense attorney." And now he's like,
"Oh no, this is exactly how I'd run this."
He He's literally the defense lure getting paid. He better be
the best one at this. Uh hopefully. Hold on. Revoke just asked,
"Am I a retard?" 1238. What the is the 38? I Yeah, you might
actually be. I'm sorry, Revoked, cuz you're a big gifter. But
uh you might actually be for not knowing what the 38 is there.
I'm sorry. That's actually really bad. The time of the crash.
He's like, "What's what's the 38 in called 12 3138?"
Hold on real quick. Overnight, the Israeli Air Force carried
out extensive strikes against military targets in Western Iran,
destroying and targeting and destroying dozens of surfaceto-surface
missile storage and launch infrastructure sites alongside surfaceto-air
missile launchers and drone storage sites oriented by the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard Corps and the Iranian Armed Forces. That
could be like degrees for like where the moon is or something.
It could latitude, longitude. Yeah, any of these things. Boom.
drones
taking out missile launchers and stuff. Crazy. Cool. Cool. Cool.
Cool. Thank you for the link. That's what their own data showed.
And it devastated their case and it devastated that false theory.
There must have been panic, I'm guessing, in the room. What were
you doing? Does the vehicle record collisions? No, but the vehicle
does record going forwards and backwards. And so I think they
say when she finished reversing, she goes forward. That has to
be in the collision was is somewhere around when the vehicle
starts going forward. The data shows John 11 struck by the car.
What do we do? Enter Shannon Burgess.
Question. Can you believe him? Can you believe Mr. Burgess? He
came up with a brand new story right in the middle of trial.
You might ask yourself, would an expert actually say something
he knows not to be true? Would an expert actually say something
he knows is not supported by fact? Would an expert shade the
truth? You don't have to look any further than Shannon Burgess's
CV to answer that question. That was a shame. Even with a poll
and push, wait, did he lie on his resume? Stretch and manipulation
of the time data that Mr. Burgess came in here and told you about
it. Still shows that John O'Keefe was very much alive and walking
around after they claimed he was hit and incapacitated. Think
about that. Matt Doga looked at Burgess's report and told you
that in 30 out of 30 scenarios of the possible time SKs that
Shannon Burgess identified, he came in in the middle of trial
and identified all these other time SKUs that he called it. In
every single scenario, John was alive and walking after they
said he was hit. And that's a problem for them because there
was no collision. Just look at Mr. Whiffen's data. Ian Whippen.
John O'Keefe took 31 steps at a steady rate about 83 ft. And
then think about this in a westerly direction. That would be
right toward the house. Remember, it's 78 ft to that garage door.
That's not a coincidence. The Commonwealth witnesses or the Commonwealth
witness Dr. Mr. Ian Whippen himself conceded that he has reasonable
doubts about the accuracy of John's location data. You remember
that question and answer my Mr. Lesie? Do you have doubts? I
do. Are those doubts reasonable? They are. And remember, still
the Commonwealth burden. If their own cell phone expert had a
reasonable doubt about John's location, so should you. John O'Keefe
was inside and the phone battery. This makes me miss Nick Rakita.
Uh Nick Rakita literally covered all of this. What are you talking
about missing Nick Rakita? Nick Rakita literally streamed all
of this. Like he streamed this entire closing argument stuff.
All of it. Yeah. I don't know what you mean. He's there streaming
it. Further, this is not speculation. This is science and it's
irrefutable. It tells us that he was laying he was not laying
outside in the cold. He was inside somewhere a little bit warmer.
Ian whiff told you that when the iPhone is exposed to freezing
temperatures, think about these numbers. When the iPhone is exposed
to freezing temperatures, it will drop from 81 to 21° in 15 minutes.
15 minutes. That's a 60° drop in 15 minutes. Now look at John's
phone. It was laying according to the Commonwealth, it was laying
directly on frozen ground. He arrived at 34 Fairview on his and
his phone dropped only 20° over the course of an hour. then inexplicably.
Oh, this is why they brought up dropping below 50° for the next.
Oh, could be. Yeah, could be. So, their their timeline doesn't
add up. Yeah, this guy's good.
He's like, "Nah, give me the iPhone records. Let's see if that
phone was really out there with him." There's a whole other thing
in the iPhone records around uh like texts and searches that
were done and we'll see if that comes up as well in the closing
arguments. But like this from other people who lived in the house
where the party was thrown. Yeah, their uh their iPhone records
very
Give me two seconds. I'll be right back. Got to use bathroom.
4 and a half hour. Never dropping below 50° for the next 4 and
1/2 hours basically through the entire night. He was not outside.
He was someplace warmer like a basement or a garage. Dr. Lapada
confirmed that John O'Keefe did not have hypothermia. No telltale
signs, no telltale wishes spot, no frostbite on any extremity.
He did not die of hypothermia because he wasn't outside. Dr.
Isaac Wolf, Dan Wolf, Elizabeth Lapasatada, Justin Welchshire,
Andrew Winsler, all agreed, every expert agreed this is how John
O'Keefe died. A rear would fall from a standing position. What
could make you fall straight back like that? Let's just think
about that for a second. What could make you fall from a standing
position at
standing up, falling straight back? Had a laceration to the right
eye consistent with a fist or a punch, then you've got your answer.
He certainly didn't sustain that wound on the back of his head
by falling backwards onto a lawn. Dr. Dr. Lapasado told you that
the patterned injury on the back of John's head could only be
produced by hitting a hard riged or ledged surface like a concrete
stair. Step what's just through that garage door. Michael Proctor
never stepped down in that garage to find out. What a shame.
And look at the arm. Just look at John's arm. You don't need
the top expert in the country. But you had him. You don't need
the top medical mind on the planet on this issue, but you had
him. These are dog bites and scratches. These are animal wounds.
Not one witness has been called in their trial. Not one. Eight
weeks in counting. Not one witness who disputes who actually
disputes that John O'Keefe's arm injuries are from a dog. The
Commonwealth could not find a single medical expert. A sing Wait,
did uh did JF really post about his wife again? I thought there
was like a sighting. Wasn't there a sighting recently of Mama
JF? I thought No, that is a that's like a 4chan post or something.
Oh, somebody said that they saw Mama JF outside like a monastery
or something like that.
Okay, that's definitely JF. That's definitely JF posting that.
Yeah, JF said that I think then JF took that like 4chan post
and then put it on Twitter and said that he contacted the police
and gave them this information. He's so relieved that Mama JF
is okay. Uh-huh. Yeah. I can't stand this. This what? This what?
Hold on. This single medical witness who would come in here and
tell you those are inconsistent with a dog bite or scratch. And
it's equally clear that there was no collision. Dr. Okay. So,
they couldn't find a medical expert to go and dispute that those
were dog bites. The Commonwealth could not find a single medical
expert, a single medical witness who would come in here and tell
you those are inconsistent with a dog bite or a scratch. And
it's equally clear that there was no collision. Dr. Lapisada
told you in probably the clearest voice in the entire trial.
You remember her testimony. He didn't get hit by a car. In her
words, he just didn't get hit by a car. You remember the question
that was posed by Mr. Brennan. Did you consider the speed of
the vehicle? And she said speed didn't matter cuz he didn't get
hit by a car. You went to AMW.
Okay. Okay, dude. This week marks the 2-year anniversary of Mama
JF leaving our home and fully disappearing in spectacular fashion.
To this day, she has not been found in spite of the massive efforts
of authorities to locate her. Before leaving, Mama JF had obsessively
read a new exemplar of permanent record by Edward Snowden, which
she had brought and explained that our cell phones are traceable
and things of that nature. Okay. Okay. He dropped me. He drove
me in the in the forest and he dropped me off and he dropped
me. She left with the family many She left the family with many
things including a Bitcoin debit card on which about $20 with
a Bitcoin dust was left. Today I spent the dust on a burger and
chicken nuggets for my family. How'd you just turn agent?
For my family.
This one's on you, Mama JF. wherever you are. That's crazy. I
can't I can't know that we are all doing awesome. This guy
know that we This guy bought a team burger on Mama JF. Okay.
On Mama JF, he grabbed himself a team burger. Let's go. That's
nuts. Is that what that burger should look like?
Uh yeah, that's about what it looks like. All right, just checking.
I could order one and take a picture for you. That's about what
they look like. JF everything that he does like this that he
researched and studies and believes like I would not put it past
that to eat a person. Okay. Like oh they didn't find the body.
Well here is the last of it in this burger. I've officially gotten
away with it. Didn't Hold on. Yeah. Didn't he literally post
like the week after he took her out into the woods or whatever?
Didn't he literally post about like using bleach to clean his
home or something? I This guy was like so insane and brazen.
It's so funny. That's crazy.
Also, Trump tweeted again real quick, real quick update.
Publicity seeking President Emanuel Mcronone of France mistakenly
said that I left the G7 summit in Canada to go back to DC to
work on a ceasefire between Israel and Iran. Wrong. He has no
idea why I'm on my way to Washington, but it has certainly has
nothing to do with a ceasefire. Much bigger than that. Whether
purposely or not, Emanuel always gets it wrong. Stay tuned.
the publicity seeking president. Yeah, that's why he got his
wife to slap him. Okay. He just wanted the publicity of his wife
here in the face. It's even more. Trump needed to go harder.
I don't know what Trump is doing, but we're not about to let
France talk on us. Not by some groomed kid. Imagine letting techone
[__] talk your country. Okay.
You got hutched as a kid. Why the Why should we listen to you?
Sorry, was that not That might not have been your point. My bad.
Yeah. No, that that's where I'm getting at. That's where I'm
at. France, the French.
That
got groomed as a kid. Don't talk [__] about us. All
right. She repeated it three times because it's true. Not just
because she says so, but because the medical evidence proves
it. The medical science proves it. There was no collision. Dr.
Wrenchler told you unequivocally and just as firmly, he didn't
get hit by a car. The Commonwealth has not met their burden.
They cannot meet their burden. The Commonwealth hasn't called
a single medical professional, not one, to testify that John's
wounds came from being hit by a car. Not Dr. Scory Bellow, not
Dr. A. Contrast that with the caliber and the quality of the
experts who came in here to tell you what is obvious to anyone
with common pent. Those wounds on his right arm are from a dog.
This was not an oversight by the Commonwealth. It's just that
there is no one out there, no matter how big a check you write.
It's not a medical expert who's going to disagree with that.
The fact is this is the central fact in the case. The only fact
that's m that matters is literally uncontested by every medical
expert. Uncontested, undisputed. There is no evidence that John
was hit by a car. None. How much more reasonable doubt could
there be? This case should be over right now. Done. Because there
was no collision. So given all that, how did Karen Reed end up
sitting here? Why is she even here? Why is she in that chair?
Why is she in this courtroom? There is a reason for that. And
it's a reason they don't want to tell you. And it's the reality
they don't want to admit to. The reason we're here is because
the system, the very system that was meant to protect her, that
was meant to protect all of us. That system has failed. system
has
badly. So now let's discuss the facts
and were not presented by the Commonwealth in this case. Over
the next few minutes, I want to talk about the utter failure
of the police to investigate this properly and to investigate
this fully.
And what you're going to see is that Michael Proctor, the lead
investigator for the Commonwealth, did nothing to actually properly
investigate this case. Let's start with the house. That's the
most logical place to start. I think you'd agree. Brian Albert
House, where John body was discovered lifeless in the lawn.
A man, a police officer is found dead on the front lawn and no
one secures the scene. No tape, no preservation of evidence,
no crime scene log, no search warrants, no consent searches,
no photographs of the house interior. They didn't treat the house
as a crime scene. And shamefully, they didn't even treat the
yard as a crime scene. The lame excuse offered by retired Lieutenant
Gallagher. It was really cold and windy, and I didn't know if
there was a crime that had been committed. What? You didn't know
that a crime had potentially been committed? You have a man laying
dead in the yard. And here are the undisputed facts that those
officers were confronted with. Black eyes. Obviously, black eyes
are consistent with a fight. Bloody nose, also consistent with
a fight. Bleeding from the face, consistent with a physical altercation.
A cut over the right eye, consistent with a punch. No coat in
the freezing cold. Not dressed for outside. Dressed for inside.
And one shoe on. I wonder where the other shoe could be. I don't
know, maybe in the house 30 ft away. And then you find a broken
and shattered drinking glass next to him. The type of glass that
you might find, I don't know, let me think about this. In a kitchen,
in a house, 30 ft away. And John's phone was tucked neatly under
his back shoulder. Lieutenant Gallagher actually claimed he did
not know it was a potential crime that needed investigating.
The neighbor across the street, Detective Lieutenant Keller,
had a ring camera. A ring camera that was pointed at the exact
direction where John Wait, what? That What do you mean? Somebody
whatever Gallagher said that he didn't know that this was a crime
that would need investigating.
What? No, I Dude, there's so many there's so many really bad
things. There's so many really bad things. Also, this is another
big one. Okay, there's a detective who lives directly across
the street who is a ring camera that looks directly over there.
Cherry, listen. Listen to this. The neighbor across the street,
Detective Lieutenant Keller, had a ring camera. A ring camera
that was pointed at the exact direction where John O'Keefe would
have been hit. And nobody bothered to secure it. Nobody bothered
to secure it. Nobody even bothered to look at it. Of course,
this was a potential crime scene. Of course, it was. They literally
like they didn't save the Ring video. What? But no, no, no. Ring
video will automatically save. You pay for the the $10 the $20
thing. um a year
and you just get the video's saved so long as it triggers the
thing to turn on.
You have to go out of your way to delete the video. There's Yeah,
I don't Let's not forget this was Brian Albert's house and that
comes with
Quote, "Is the homeowner going to catch any?" Nope. He's a Boston
cop, too. End quote. That quote starts to make a little more
sense now, doesn't it? Michael Crocker wrote those words just
hours after John's body was found. He sent this in a private
chat, in a private text. he never ever believed would ever be
revealed. He sent that text in a series of messages that now
belong to you. You weren't given the opportunity to hear from
48 hours that you can read. Not for it would just stay there.
That's what you end up paying for. And there's no way that you're
a detective and you don't just dish out the 10 or the $20
to be able to have that like security footage.
Well, uh it was not found. It was not found. Thoughts yourself
and I urge you go read them. They're in exhibit 209 209 in case
you're wondering. But here are the highlights. Proctor starts
the conversation. Quote, "All the powers that be," one answered
ASAP. He's getting pregnant, obviously. Get this done. His friend
then asks what Proctor's probably thinking at the time. Quote,
I assume you guys are out to make it cut and dry since it involves
cops.
Something stinks. And Proctor responds, "Yeah,
to the something stinks." And then he goes on, "But there will
be some serious charges brought on the girl. Think about that.
Hours into this investigation, there will be some serious charges
brought on the girl. She's a whack job.
Yeah, she's a babe. Weird Fall River accent, though. No, no.
She's got a leaky. These are all These are all one of the cops
who was investigating, right? This is Proctor's texts. Balloon
leaks poo. Zero chance.
Did you just comment on her job, [__] Yeah, she's
a babe. Weird fall accent though. No. No.
She's got a leaky balloon on, leaks poo. Zero chance she skates.
She's
And up to this point, Michael Proctor had done zero investigation,
nothing,
save to a grand total of three people, all of whom were named
Albert or McCabe. That's it. And this was his mindset.
This is the same leading investigator who sent the group chat
that you heard about with Sergeant Bupnick late night sitting
at his office rifling through Karen's phone bragging about looking
for naked pictures of her. That pack wasn't sent to his buddies
or his friends. That text was sent to his supervisors at the
Massachusetts State Police for God's sake. And what was their
response? Oh, it was the state cops that were looking into this.
I see. Yeah, right. Duchenick liked this conduct with a big old
thumbs
He encouraged it.
Ladies and gentlemen, a lead investigator is every investigator
is supposed to be objective. An objective factf finder. No bias,
no agenda. Michael Proper went far beyond just insulting Karen
Reed. He dehumanized this woman. He betrayed her as a human being.
He was fired for his blatant bias. If the Massachusetts State
Police can't trust him, how can you trust him with this investigation
and with your verdict
and with Karen Reed's life?
The lead investigator in a murder trial was never called to testify.
Think about that. That should stop you in your tracks. Wouldn't
you want to hear from Michael Proctor? Wouldn't you want to hear
from the lead investigator in the case? Don't you have questions?
The Commonwealth did not present their own lead investigator
to the jury, the very jury who is charged with judging the
Michael Proctor clearly is radioactive and the Commonwealth stayed
away from it. Michael Proctor is no longer a Massachusetts State
Police officer. He wasn't transferred. He didn't go on sobatical.
He didn't retire. He didn't resign. He was fired. He was terminated
for cause. The Massachusetts State Police investigated him and
found him guilty of dishonorable conduct. Not just for those
text messages, folks. For sharing confidential information with
witnesses, and for bias. Not just any bias. Bias in this case.
Fired.
This is the man who touched every
I know. He's He's always He's so good. Hold on. I'll back in
this case. Fired.
He's so good. This is the man who touched every single piece
of important evidence in this case. All the evidence that was
brought before you in this trial went through his hands one way
or another. The shirts, the shards. Remember that when Mr. Brennon
gets up and gives his closing argument, the shirts, the shards,
all in Michael Proctor's possession. Mr. Brennan and the Commonwealth,
I think, is have pinned their hopes on some microscopic pieces
of or close to microscopic pieces of plastic that were claimed
to have been from the hoodie several months after the fact.
What he failed to ask every single investigator, I'm sorry, every
single witness is who had access to that shirt and who had access
to the tail light guidance. And the answer is it was Michael
Proctor. Not for days, not for weeks, for months on end. For
months unaccounted for, before they were submitted to the crime
lab, before they were ever. Just go look at the chain of custody
documents. You got them. Why didn't Michael Proctor give those
clothes to I mean, they keep saying no, but like didn't we literally
look to his home? Wrong video. Wrong video. Hold on. It was the
other one.
Wait, wait, wait, wait. They That guy says no. But like
Oh my god. Do you remember?
He remembers the moment when there was over ass. Like come on.
I'm sorry. I did I did actually remember. So I Marine Hartnet
in the crime lab when she was at Hampton PD just days after the
fact to receive those solo cups. Remember that? Just a few days
later she was there. She drove up. She did the driving to take
the solo cups in the grocery bag which has a ridiculous aspect
to it in and of itself as well. Why not just give her the shirts
as well? the tail light fragment if any were found at that point.
Why hold on to them? What could possibly be a reason? Why wait
until March to book those into evidence?
Now, let's talk about some of the other problems with the Commonwealth's
evidence. As I indicated, there was no blood, no skin, no tissue,
no DNA found on a single piece or shard of the tail light that
the Commonwealth claims cut and sliced into John O'Keefe's arm.
Where is that trace evidence? Where is that biological evidence?
The DNA, where is it? They got nothing. Not a single piece that
the Commonwealth wants you to believe cut up John's arm. How
is that possible? It's not possible. The only way it's possible
is if those shards never touched his arm because it was a dog.
Oh, and the one sample of DNA that they did find, by the way,
was found on the outer smooth part of the housing. Not any shard.
It was the outer smooth part of the housing. Nothing that they
claim actually came in contact with John O'Keefe. Number two,
that sample had DNA of two other men, two other unidentified
males.
That tells you that that DNA had nothing to do with a car strike.
That DNA would be expected to Those were DNA and the shards.
be John's DNA would be expected to be all over that car inside,
outside. He had access to that car for months and months and
months. He was in and out of it all the time. Show me some blood,
then we'll talk. They can't and they won't because it doesn't
exist. The SUV never hit.
The hair found on the bumper. The Commonwealth really stretched
its own credibility on this one. That magic little hair on the
SUV supposedly survived a 37 mile drive in 47 mph winds. But
that little magic hair just clung there. Just hung on. That same
hair that moved in between photos in the Sallyport. Remember
that? There were two photos taken and it was either the breath
of the photographer or just the movement of walking by the hair.
It literally moved between the two photographs. But that hair
is supposed to have hung on in a 37 mile drive in a blizzard.
The only thing that hair proves that the Commonwealth is embarrassingly
grafting at straws. That hair has nothing to do with anything.
But it doesn't stop there. There was another revelation at trial,
a big one, a huge one, and it came from a very unlikely source.
Christina Hanley, a quiet, reserved criminalist who told you
something the Commonwealth likely did not want revealed because
it's devastating to their case. Absolutely devastating. And it's
this.
The glass on the bumper didn't match the glass. All right.
Remember February 11th, Michael Proctor, without any other person
with him. No witness, no supervisor, no other person with him,
claims to have found a single piece of glass at the scene. February
11th, single piece of glass, Michael Proctor. Keep that in mind.
Interestingly, the glass on the bumper that didn't match the
glass, one piece did match one other thing, the Proctor glass.
Those two go together. The only two things that go together from
that bumper are the Proctor glass.
There was we know that there's no glass in the tail light. We
know that there nothing else was shattered on the vehicle. Therefore,
that glass had to be placed there. Didn't come from a crash.
Didn't come from a a glass. So, how did it get sprinkled on the
back of the bumper? Whose proverbial fingerprints are on that
glass on the bumper? The only thing that matched, it's Michael
Proctor.
What about the Ford Edge and that snowplow driver, Brian Lan?
He observed that Ford Edge parked outside Brian Albert's house
at 3:30 a.m. That vehicle was moved directly in front of where
John's body was found sometime between 2:30 and 3:30 in the morning.
The only person connected to a car of that making model, Brian
Albert. Michael Proctor did nothing to investigate that point.
Did nothing to investigate whose board head was parked in a in
a spot specifically to block the line of sight in the exact position
where John's body would be later found by Karen Reed. No one,
not Michael Proctor or anybody else checked it for evidence.
No one even asked any questions about it. That Ford Edge, Brian
Albert Ford Edge, completely ignored. Michael Proctor failed
to interview obvious witnesses in this case. Why? Why didn't
he want to speak to the snowplow driver, Brian Lren? Why did
he falsely claim that no one plowed the roadway that morning
when police dash cam video? You saw the dash cam. It shows plows
going back and forth all morning. Why did he wait so long, years
even, to interview Heather Maxon and Ryan Nagel, individuals
who were literally outside 34th Fair View at the exact same time
John and Karen arrived at Brian Albert's house that night. Brian
Lran had he been investigated or interviewed would have told
Michael Proctor that he drove past the lawn multiple times on
January 29th and there was no body on the lawn.
He would have had the perfect view. Remember, the weatherman
told you there was only enough snow at that time. I think he
said this jury is out for more than a few hours. I'll be stunned.
Absolutely should be out in like 20 minutes. Well, Romus, they
had the first day was 2 hours of deliberations at the end of
closing arguments at the end of these statements. They deliberated
for 2 hours and then today they had a full day of deliberations.
This was Friday. Then today they had a full day of deliberations
and they are not they do not have a verdict yet. So, I assume
the prosecution has something in the closing arguments where
they make a case.
And how the prosecution's going to talk for an hour and 20 minutes.
What the are they going to say?
I have no idea. I got no clue. They're just going to reverse
Uno and be like, "No, there was a collusion."
That's Well, I did notice the way he says things is like not
a single one of them said that this was um not a single expert
said that it was conclusively a collision. So like I feel like
some experts come up there and go yeah I'm pretty sure it's a
collision. It's possible it's like do you know for sure it's
possible? Not for sure. Yeah. So it's like it depends on what
the actual language is. If you are really really ballsy in going
after this guy, you could try to say like here's the way he presented
this to you, but here's like what was actually said, right? Like
they said, oh, they're they they feel like it's consistent with
a collision, but he's willing to tell you that it like wasn't
a collision at all. It's not proven at all, even though they're
like, "Oh, their best guess is collision kind of thing." I don't
know. I don't think he'll end up doing that, though. I also don't
know who No, he had to because he's going to have first. He's
the one who had the experts that say the um the force that would
have been necessary to break the tail light would have shattered
the dude's bones. And you can see in the x-ray nothing shattered.
Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yep.
I mean I it sounds like there's a couple different things like
that is it sounded like multiple not just one expert but multiple
experts said like yeah you would expect broken bones like somehow.
glass from it plastic from the the tail light or whatever on
him. They waited till what years later for microscopic versions
to be found on him. There was glass on him but not in his arm
I don't think. And I think the exact thing they hypothesiz is
his arm got hit first. So I think there was some glass on him.
It just wasn't in his arm at all which is like where he got hit
and then where all those cuts are and stuff which is weird. What
exactly? He said that there was nothing, not glass, um like the
the tail light would be something and there was nothing on him.
Um it wasn't until months later that he made a big deal of it.
Like the evidence was in his hands. The evidence was in his hands.
That's why it's weird years later that
now they find microscopic plastic shards or whatever. Yes. Right.
Right. Right. There's no glass on him. There was glass broken
around him. Like they found glass in the lawn. But apparently
they didn't find glass in the lawn immediately which but like
none stuck in his skin or anything like that, right? Yes. Yeah.
None on his person. True. True. Praise only enough snow to track
a cat. I think that was it.
There were no body there. Heather Maxon and Ryan Nagel would
have told him that they arrived at 34 Fairview shortly after
Karen and John pulled up behind them and they would have told
Michael Proctor, at least Heather would have told Michael Proctor
that when she left 10 minutes later, she drove past the SUV and
observed Karen Reed in the driver's side, dome light on, passenger
seat empty. So, where was John? Wasn't outside, wouldn't sitting
down, wasn't laying down. There's only one place he could be.
We all say it together if you could talk with me. He was in the
house.
Michael Proctor did not want to have those answers. He did not
want to have to disclose those answers. He didn't want the truth.
The Commonwealth has presented a shred of evidence of when Karen
Reed consumed her last drink that night. Think about that. It's
critical information that the Commonwealth has to prove beyond
a reasonable doubt and to a moral certainty. They have to prove
when her last drink was that night. They have to prove it. We
don't have to prove or disprove anything.
Every single witness who was asked and who had an opportunity
to observe Karen that night said the same thing. She wasn't drunk.
She wasn't stumbling. Wasn't fluring her words. She was, in the
words of Miss Kipas, completely normal. Even Jennifer McCabe
grudgingly had to admit that fact. It's on video. Instead, they
use Yuri Buchanan to try to come into court and count sips of
alcohol, which he admittedly got wrong.
According to Ian Wan, the Commonwealth phone expert, location
data, using location data on Jon's phone showed Karen driving
lawfully. She was driving safely. She was under the speed limit.
She was slowing and stopping at stop signs, slowing around corners,
and Ryan Nagel corroborated that when he saw her make that left-hand
turn onto Fair View. The Commonwealth has an incredibly high
burden to prove that Karen was driving under the influence. They
have failed to prove that beyond a reasonable doubt and to a
moral certainty because it depends on when she had her last drink.
What happened after she got home and she was upset with John
for not coming? What are we thinking? Did the cops do it? I think
the cops train this lady. I mean, based on what I've seen, it's
very I think the all of the camera footage, there's like CCTV
footage that should have shown her driving home that didn't.
And there's supposed to be ring footage from across the street
that was just gone and never checked. If honestly, if she did
it, she almost should get off because
they did such a job investigating. Like, like you shouldn't be
able to do this poor a job investigating as a Commonwealth and
and find somebody guilty. Like that, right? If you do this bad
a job investigating, you don't collect actual evidence. You do
nothing to preserve the crime scene. You're just total dog [__]
Like, you shouldn't be able to throw people in jail. You coming
back out of the house?
That would answer that question.
As you well know, no one searched the house for signs of a struggle.
Not that night. Not the next day. I'm talking about 34 Fairview.
Not ever. Not once. Not with a warrant. Not with consent. They
never went to the basement, the stairwells. They didn't look
at the walls. They didn't look in the garage. Nothing was ever
examined. Nothing was checked for for blood. Nothing was checked
for DNA. They didn't look for a ledge, a riged surface. Zero.
You'll remember how surprised Jennifer McCabe was to recall.
Unfortunately, Alpha Kilo, because they did such a horrible job
investigating, I don't think you could prove that any of the
cops did it beyond a reasonable doubt either, right? Like you
you would need there's just no way to there's no evidence. So,
even if it's like, oh, they find her not guilty, right? I think
I think there's basically no way
even if they find her not guilty that they could possibly charge
the cops. I think it's just over. that there was a garage door
even on the house. Except this was her sister's house. She's
been going to that house since she was five. She's seen that
house. She's been in and out of that house hundreds of times,
maybe thousands of times. She's been going to that house her
entire life. And yet she acted surprised when I asked her about
it. Remember down from a cave's answer when I asked her whether
whether there was a door at the garage. I was asking her about
the front door, the side door, and the garage door. And her answer
was, "Oh, actually there is a garage door right there."
And investigators never opened that
Let's change the scenario. What if it wasn't the house of a Boston
cop? What What if it wasn't the house of Brian Albert? We can
be certain that investigators would have torn that house apart
to get answers about why a fellow police officer was laying dead
on the homeowner's lawn. You can bet. I think
But because this was Brian's house, a Boston cop? Nope.
And because he was a fellow cop, an insider, they didn't even
open the door. That is not justice, folks. That's just pure favoritism.
Each of these facts is more than a question mark. They're failures
of duty. They're blank spots on a map where justice is supposed
to live. And every single one is a reason why you cannot convict
Karen Reed. Reasonable doubt abounds. If the Commonwealth failed
to investigate every reasonable alternative, how dare they how
dare they come in here and ask you for a verdict. They didn't
investigate the case fully and yet they're asking you to take
the easy road and do their job for them.
These fact do not represent reasonable doubt. Nothing does. Every
one of these facts that you're thinking that we're talking about
represent reasonable doubt. Everyone. The police and the prosecution
are in a position to take people's liberty. It's the most dire
and consequential act a civilized government can take against
one of its citizens. Their obligation is not just to try to get
it right. They have to convince you to the highest degree of
certainty known in human affairs. They have to do it all, every
bit of it beyond any and all reasonable doubt. And they have
not done that here. And how about the homeowner himself, the
host, the first responder, the Boston cop, Brian Albert, who
was sparring and practiced fighting with Brian Higgins just minutes
before John O'Keefe appeared at his house, 34th Fairview. Brian
Albert, who was watching clearly that night, the German Shepherd.
Brian Albert, whose phone and his wife's phone were never secured.
Brian Albert, who never came out of the house, but that doesn't
mean he wasn't awake. It doesn't mean that he was not. Fun fact,
Judge Cacophanies, you're super into this, by the way. You are
all the way in this. Okay. Fun fact, Judge Bev owes her job.
Wait, Cacophony, did you have a different name when you were
here talking about this the first time? Are you like uh you're
not like ES Anderson or something, are you? Trying to think of
who this could because I feel like somebody also had like insane
knowledge about this the first time we watched. I'm trying to
see if it's the same person. Fun fact, Judge Bev owes her job
to the DA because he recommended her for the position by proxy.
So, she owes him favors. There's a reason for her rulings are
so when normally she gets overturned in appeals for ruling too
much in favor of the defendant. No, but I've been following this
for years. Auntie Bev is what they call the judge. Her name is
Beverly something. And she was called Auntie Bev by maybe the
is it the nephew of Brian Albert? One of the Alberts. Okay. One
of the one of the guys whose house the party was at. Somebody
in that family called her auntie. Think about this. Jennifer
McCabe claimed that her sister and Brian Albert both slept through
this complete chaos right outside their bedroom window. But Jennifer
McCabe's phone records tell a different story. And they tell
the truth. She spoke with him for the better part of a minute,
38 seconds to be detailed about it at 5:07 a.m. And then she
lied about that call. Remember that?
What was the reason for that call at 507? Was it panic? Was it
a warning?
We know that conversation took place at the precise time Karen
left her house to go search for John. 507.
We could answer those questions if we just had access to their
phone. Brian Albert, Brian Higgins. But Michael Proctor wasn't
interested in their phones. Not only did he not secure their
phones, he never even asked.
And what about Brian Albert's dog, Chloe? A dog with a history.
A dog that is quote not good with strangers. Dr. Russell confirmed
that John's patterned injuries were from a dog just like the
dog Brian Albert owned.
And then Chloe just disappeared.
Not there the next morning. None of the officers that you heard
from said that there was a dog in the house. They didn't see
her. Just gone and then ultimately gotten rid of altogether.
Who gets rid of their family pet
unless they had something to hide.
Michael Proctor wasn't interested in that either. And recall
the group chat with the Alberts and the Mabes. They were getting
their story straight. Matt McCabe, whom the Commonwealth did
not call in this trial, instructed the group in that group chat,
you'll recall, "Tell him to say the guy never came in the house."
Think about that exact quote. Tell him to say the guy never came
in the house. And Brian Albert, the patriarch of the family.
Exactly. Exclamation point. He blessed it.
But the truth, as we all know, you don't need to get your story
straight. You don't need to tell someone what to say. It's just
just the truth.
And what about the Google search? A Google search that Jennifer
McCabe admitted having made. A Google search that was timestamped
by Celebrite at 2:27 a.m. A Google search that read how long
to die in cold. It is uncontested and undisputed that that search
was deleted. If the 227 a.m. time stamp is not true, why does
Jennifer McCabe have to lie about it? Why delete it? If the 227
a.m. time stamp is not true, why create a false story about Karen
screaming Google hypothermia? That's just a fabrication. That's
just a madeup fact. And by the way, if someone does tell you
Google hypothermia,
why would you Google how long it takes to die in cold? Wouldn't
you just Google
Jennifer McCaben listed Carrie Robert to help shift the blame
to Karen.
Why go to that much effort? Unless you're trying to cover for
something.
Keep in mind the entire foundation, the entire foundation of
her claim that Karen said Google hypothermia is this fantasy
about Karen screaming it at the location at the scene. That's
her entire excuse. But that story went completely off the rails
when it's cacophony guys very into this facts in this case. Dead
cop on lawn. Cop in house doesn't come out ever. Cop cop's friends
go to headquarters randomly at 1:30 a.m. Every member involved
destroyed their phones including the ATF ATF1 who broke his phone
and disposed of it in multiple dumpsters at on base. The dog
disappeared. The floor is redone. Sold the multigenerational
family home.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think the dude stayed inside to handle his
dog and the mess for sure. It's spooky. When Kerry Roberts admitted
that she perjured herself to back up Jennifer McCabe's false
story, that was a dramatic moment in court. It's an admission
of perjury. And you don't see that very often in a courtroom.
That tells you everything you need to know about the character
and quality of the prosecution's case and their witnesses. Lying
and perjury and admitting to it. Oh, they got a fundamental tenant
of any investigation is to ensure that witnesses are independent.
And they got what? Oh. They got rid of it already. Wait, wait.
The dog wasn't The dog wasn't gone the next morning, was it?
No, they're saying by the time that um they had people come to
like they found the body or whatever, that the dog was gone.
Like they handled it that night. The dog wasn't there by the
time they found his body. Wait, but the dog was there that day?
There's no way they testified that they got rid of the dog that
day. They must have said the dog was gone like a week before
or something, right?
How the was the dog gone?
Yes, that night. There's no way they're on test. They testified
saying we got rid of the dog that night. There's no
way on this planet of Earth that they actually came out and were
like when somebody asked, "Wait, what happened to the dog?" They're
like, "Well, that night we happen to get rid of the dog. There's
no way." You know what happened?
I was just taking my dog on a walk and this uh congresswoman
Nancy, she
she said I got to put this dog down.
Oh, wait. She wouldn't have been a congresswoman at that time,
I don't think. Wait, she wasn't a congresswoman. She's governor,
right?
Yeah. Yeah.
Uh, wait. What the [__] is her name? Christy. Christy,
not Nancy. You're thinking of Pelosi. It's Christy Gnome. Oh,
okay. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Christy Gnome. And not influenced by
other witnesses.
You start by separating the witnesses. Michael Proctor did none
of that in this case and we see the results. Think back to Jennifer
McCabe's own text messages with Carrie Roberts.
What Carrie Roberts, sorry, about Carrie Roberts, not with Carrie
Roberts, notably. What Carrie Roberts didn't know was that at
the time she was being interviewed by the police, Jennifer McCabe
was in real time she was bragging about having influenced Car's
testimony or her statements to the Alberts and the Mades. Quote,
she's telling them everything, all the stuff. Remember that timeline
that we talked about with Jennifer McCabe? That's what she was
referring to. She's telling him everything. everything that Jennifer
McCabe had put in Carrie Roberts timeline. The Commonwealth want
you to believe that Karen Reed made a statement at the location
at the scene, I hid him. I'm sure you'll hear that from the prosecution
in their final arguments. But their own witnesses contradict
that. Jennifer McCabe admitted on that her very first statement
to law enforcement, her first statement to law enforcement confirmed
that Karen didn't say anything. She asked, "Could I have hit
him? Did I hit him? Is he dead?" The physics and the science
answer that question. Could you have hit him? No, it couldn't
have. Sergeant Buchanan also testified that the only statement
Kieran Reed made at the scene according to his conversations
with the first responders was, "Could I have hit him? Did I hit
him?" It wasn't a confession. It was confusion. And Dr. Russell
explained that confusion. She told you why Karen Reed or anybody
in that position might ask those questions. She was suffering
from extreme grief reaction, which according to the evidence
can last for years. Even her medical records confirm that diagnosis.
It's common to ask those questions in grief. It's common to ask
those types of questions in shock. You're trying to make sense
out of the nonsensical in the moment. And the Commonwealth has
tried to twist those words into a confession. There is no evidence
that any officer at the scene ever heard Karen Reed say, "I hit
him." Not a single police officer at the scene came in to support
the Commonwealth's claim. It's not on video. It's not on audio.
Not a single police report. It's not in a single EMT or EMS report.
Nowhere. The fact is Kieran never said, "I hit him." You saw
the video. Multiple officers were right there. She simply never
said it. What did Jennifer McCabe do and not do when she got
to 34 Fair View? She would have you believe, I want to set the
scene for you that she's confronted out of the blue with John
O'Keefe's lifeless body, her friend John O'Keefe, be bruised
and battered. He's bleeding. His eyelid is cut. His nose is bleeding.
Karen is screaming at the top of her lungs. Carrie Carrie is
screaming back to Karen. Shut up. Both women begin crying. Both
women are giving CPR. There's chaos everywhere. It's building
in the yard just feet from Brian Albert's house. Brian Albert's
window. Jennifer calls her sister at 6:07. With all this chaos
going on, no answer. Jennifer calls her sister at 6:08. With
all this chaos in bedum going on, still no answer. No lights
come on in the house. In the midst of all this screaming and
this chaos, Brian Albert doesn't come outside. Nicole Albert
doesn't come outside during this mastrom. And yet Jennifer McCabe
never goes inside to check on her sister.
There's literally no signs of life inside the house. And Jennifer
McCabe doesn't take a foot a step inside that house to check
on her family. Why is that? Does that make any sense? Anyone
Everyone would sprint inside the house to make sure that there's
no one in there that was hurt or injured or god forbid dead.
Everyone would do that, but not Jennifer McCabe. The only way
that makes sense is if Jennifer McCabe already knew that Brian
and Nicole were just fine.
That's the only reasonable explanation. And the only way she
would know that they were fine is if she knew what
But Michael Proctor never explored this incredibly suspicious
behavior.
Don't you have questions?
This would give anyone reasonable doubt.
And don't you have questions also about Brian Higgins?
Michael Proctor certainly didn't. Higgins had been sending flirtatious
and romantic text to John's girlfriend Karen Reed. You'll remember
I asked Sergeant Buchanan a simple question. Were those texts
flirtatious in nature? He refused to answer that simple question.
Do you remember that? Quote, I'm not comfortable putting a label
on that. End quote. We read the texts. It's not a secret. Of
course they were flirtatious. Of course they were romantic in
nature. The reason he refused to answer that simple question
is telling. It's because these flirtatious texts established
a motive for Brian Higgins. Sergeant Buchanan could not bring
himself to tell the truth. His bias was on full display. He was
covering for another cop.
Investigators also ignore ignored Higgins suspicious late night
visit to the Canton Police Department. That was after a night
of drinking, by the way. Why didn't they investigate this? What
was so important that Higgins need to go needed to go to the
police station at that time, 1:30 in the morning, while drunk?
By the way,
like that's another thing. Yeah. The guy who they basically say
wanted to fight John O'Keefe, the guy who died, the the dude
who we saw was like, "Let's go outside." That guy goes That guy
goes at 1:30 in the morning to a police department drunk.
Like what? What are you What are you doing? Why were they interested
in knockbacks?
Remember, he's an ATF agent. He's a cop, a member of the Blue
Wall, and best friends with Brian Albert.
He would know that the CPD would be the first to get the call
when someone reported John missing or injured. He would know
what to look for, what to listen for to determine if a report
had been made and when, and what the response was going to be.
You saw the sculpting through the hallways with the hood up,
moving bags between cars, and of course that late night mysterious
phone call on his cell phone. A phone that you don't have and
that you'll never see.
All of that. And Michael Proctor never gave him a second look.
All of that in the Commonwealth, who's supposed to be after the
truth, didn't call him to the stand. If you have any unanswered
questions about Brian Higgins, that's reasonable doubt.
The police didn't interview Brian Higgins on January 29th, 2022,
but he was at the police station. As we've just seen, you heard
evidence that Higgins and Chief uh Chief of Police Kenny Burkowitz,
also good friends, were in the Sallyport together with the SUV
for a quote wildly long time. Kelly Deborah, another Boston cop,
told you that. She also told law enforcement agents that she
found it quote weird that Higgins could have access to that very
sensitive evidence, the SUV.
Folks, there is never a situation in which a witness, a potential
suspect even, should be given access to the evidence in a case.
But that's exactly what happened here. Higgins would give unfettered
access to that SUV and its tail light nearly immediately according
to Kelly De's statement to law enforcement. And it was at that
exact time, the exact moment that Higgins would be in that Salport
that the 42 minutes of the Salport video was just missing. It's
just gone, vanished. Well, that's convenient.
Now, put in context the condition of that tail light when it
was actually seized in Don. It was cracked but not completely
damaged. I ask you to compare and contrast officer Kelly De,
her attitude, her demeanor. That's all for you to judge. her
attitude, her demeanor, her truthfulness, her motives from the
witness stand.
Oh, by the way, this is the same county where that cop killed
the teenage girl he was abusing and thought he got uh and thought
he got pregnant. Then people covered it up and now it turns out
it wasn't even his baby. So, they have they have the DNA test
like everyone. Okay, compare and contrast that to Sergeant Nick
Barrow. What the is wrong with Austin?
Uh, or whatever the suburb is. Little Rock, is that where it
is? Little Rock is the suburb. Be more believable. Officer Baros
is unattached to any of the players in this grand play directed
by Michael Proctor. He's truly independent. And what did he tell
you? Was the tail light? He was asked, "Was the tail light in
this condition when Michael Proctor picked up that SUV at 412?"
His answer, absolutely not. Absolutely not. It was cracked, but
not completely damaged. Not smashed out like that. So, how did
the tail light get cracked? How did it end up in the condition
where it was cracked as Officer Barrow saw it, but not completely
damaged? Will you even have to guess?
There's a video. Just watch.
That's how it got cracked. And Judson Welchure's own recreation
confirms it.
Look at the contact. That's from the Commonwealth expert. And
that photo is confirmed by the fact that there were no tail light
pieces found in any of the initial searches conducted at the
scene. Two searches, 50 foot area searched. Not a single fragment
was found until after until until after Michael Proctor had access
to and control of that SUV and its tail light. What does that
say about the character and quality of this case? It's revealing
what happened here at trial. One of the most dramatic moments
probably of the trial. Kelly Deborah.
How can you trust this investigation when you saw how far a police
officer will go? You had a front row seat to the power of police
manipulation and police corruption. A front row seat. Kelly Deborah
was interviewed by a separate law enforcement agency, not a friendly
department, not Boston Police Department, not Michael Proctor's
MSP, a different independent agency. She told the law enforcement
agent in a formal interview that she saw Brian Higgins and Chief
Kenneth Burowitz alone in the Sallyport with the SUV. She was
detailed. She was clear. She was unequivocal. She remembered
the specifics. She recalled how it made her feel quote weird.
She recalled uh that how long Higgins spent a quote wildly long
time as she described. These are all incredible details to tell
law enforcement. She couldn't have been clearer. She couldn't
have been more specific. But then she's put on a witness list
and she's subpoenaed by the defense.
Oh boy.
Then this rookie cop was called up to the police commissioners,
the same commissioner that was boss of Brian Albert. They have
a meeting, private meeting, and he says, wink wink, nod nod,
we support you, officer de. What else was said in that meeting?
What else is reasonable to believe was said in that meeting?
She claimed she couldn't remember. She claimed not to remember
if he instructed her to do the right thing. But the commissioner
of the Boston Police Department certainly said something to this
rookie cop. And all of a sudden, that detailed, unambiguous,
unequivocal statement to law enforcement became what? What did
she say?
A false memory.
Not I didn't say it. She admitted she said it. She admitted she
detailed the entire story. She just said it's a false memory.
What?
So, she's called to the commissioner's office to make sure that
she would do the Sorry, that was uh that was good. The entire
story. She just said it's a false memory. Here it is. Here it
is. Here it is.
What?
So, she called to the commissioner office to make sure that she
would do the right thing. That's why she was called. And now
we know what that means. In her words, "My entire career depends
on what I say here on the stand." I'll quote that again. Quote,
"My entire career depends on what I say here on the
You bet it does. That's how it works. And that's how we got here.
Why? At the end of the day, you have to ask yourself, can you
trust the Commonwealth's case? Can you trust their witnesses?
Can you trust their evidence? And here are a few of the highlights.
A video that was played in a courtroom and sold is accurate.
Turns out it was completely inverted, flipped backward, completely
false. Oh, I thought they were not allowed to show this. I thought
they were not allowed to show this. Somebody told me this was
actually inadmissible. Now you that like the video will be evidence,
but the fact that they inverted it could not be used against
them. Is it possible? Hold on.
Uh, I know there's like different rules, like there are certain
things that you shouldn't do as an attorney
um during the trial, but then closing statements, it's like all
hands off.
Okay.
Somebody told me this would be absolutely inadmissible in the
next uh in this retrial. So, that's interesting to me that it's
not inadmissible.
I'll look it up.
M h that form the basis of their entire theory of the case. Watch
closely as Dr. Welchure stands as a servant.
Is that a righteous test or is that a manipulation? Dr. Welch
tried to deceive and fool you by leaning into the car, manipulating
the result of his own test.
When the truth was revealed by Dr. Wrenchler, the comwell spent
the next hour across the examination of his own that manipulation.
Dr. Dr. Welch tried to deceive What did he What did he try to
do? Is it going in here?
Is that a righteous test or is that a manipulation? Dr. Welch
tried to deceive and fool you by leaning into the car, manipulating
the results of his own test. Okay. When the truth was revealed
by Dr. Wrenchler, the Comall spent the next hour about
closing statements can't contain things that weren't in the trial.
Commonwealth is the one who inverted it. It's the only evidence
there is. Yeah, but I thought I thought because they wouldn't
invert it when they hand it over the next time, but whatever.
It's fine. Not a big deal. How that test was meaningless. It
actually didn't mean anything. Well, that's convenient now that
we realize it was a manipulated test and it actually does mean
nothing. It didn't represent the theory of the Commonwealth's
case. That's what was suggested. That test does not represent
the theory of the Commonwealth's case. Really? Then why was Dr.
Welchure playing dress up in John O'Keefe's clothes for identical
clothes to John O'Keefe when he was holding a glass? Why was
he holding the glass right behind the vehicle? And why was he
standing with his right arm oriented to the right rear tail light
if he wasn't trying to recreate the circumstant that is the Commonwealth
entire theory?
The communal stood up here with a straight face and told you
they weren't trying to suggest that that's how John was hit by
the car. Of course they were trying to suggest that they're theory
of the case. They only abandoned it two days ago when it was
revealed by our experts that it's physically impossible. That
silent witness that science that physics has become very pesky
to the Commonwealth because there was no mouth is back. Wait,
but he he has a mouth. No, no, no, no. We're not calling him
No Mouth when he has a mouth. We knew he was here. He is the
uh he's got to be the not the transcriber. What do you call it?
Stenographer. He's got to be the stenographer, right? There was
no collision.
Dr. also told you that there were no X-rays taken of John's arm.
He tried to deceive you into believing that John's arm might
have been broken. I don't know. I didn't see any X-rays, so I
can't tell you what the damage was inside the arm. Really? The
Commonwealth has had those X-rays in their possession for 3 years.
And again, it took the defense to bring out the truth. The X-rays
do not fit the Commonwealth's theory, so you weren't shown. And
Dr. Welchure wasn't going to admit it. And my goodness, I did
see the steno with the thing on her mouth. So I don't know what
that guy's doing then. Then we get to the sweatshirt. No breaks.
No breaks. No breaks. Not in the hand, not in the forearm, not
in the elbow, not shoulder. Stood here in front of you and grammatically
held up John's sweatshirt.
Not just to the witness, but to you and asked Dr. Wolf about
it multiple times,
specifically while it was in that plexiglass, asked Dr. Wolf
about the multiple holes in the back of the sweatshirt. He interrupted
Dr. Wolf. And Dr. will started to look at the sweatshirt and
say, "Well, I" And he said, "How about here? Here here's a hole.
Here's a hole. Here's a hole. Here's a hole." Dramatically tapping
on that plexiglass.
It was clear what the suggestion was. That the holes in the back
of John's sweatshirt were from January 29th.
That's the impression that was expected to be left with you.
That's the impression that he wanted to live with you. And that's
false.
The truth is the Commonwealth created those holes. They aren't
holes from Road Rash. They weren't made on January 29th. Those
are cutings from the Commonwealth's own crime lab, folks. That's
what those holes are.
And even with three prosecutors, all three of them sitting right
there in the room at the time.
It had to be the defense to correct that record, to bring out
the truth. If we hadn't done that, what impression would you
folks have been left with?
That's more than negligence.
That's dangerous. Dangerous.
I'm going to guess that Mr. Brennon is not going to say much
about this, about the fraud that was attempted on you. And if
he doesn't, speak louder than any concoctive excuse that the
Commonwealth might come up with. It's shameful. It's shameful.
We are after the truth in this courtroom.
You're entitled to it. Demand
Why would the Commonwealth
stoop to a stunt like that?
Desperation.
They know what you now know. What their experts know. There was
no collision.
So now we've reached the final moments of the trial and you've
seen the facts and you've seen the evidence and we've just talked
about dozens and dozens and dozens of facts that are reasonable
doubt. Each one of them are reasonable doubts. These fact these
note cards looking up pile
one on top of another literally stacks and stats.
I looked it up and maybe the thing that you're thinking of that
came from this was it was first brought up in efforts to completely
dismiss the case against uh Karen Reed and that did not successfully
happen as you can see like this still still went to trial but
nothing about this was ever
Okay, weird.
We had this whole thing in chat. As you mentally sip through
those cards, realize that every one of them is a massive hole
in the Commonwealth's case. Every single one of the the note
cards represents a hole in the Commonwealth's case. If you're
holding mentally even one of those cards, you're holding reasonable
doubt. Folks, you're holding a not guilty verdict. Reasonable
doubt is not a sliding scale. It's a wall. If the Commonwealth
cannot get over every one of these dozens of walls, you have
to acquit Karen Reed. The truth is Karen Reed is not guilty.
Not because of technicalities, but because of the facts, the
law, the science, the physics, the data, they all say so. They
demand it. The Commonwealth does not have a theory about how
John was hit by the car. They haven't even shown you that it's
possible that he was hit by a car. And the reason they haven't
is because it's not possible that he was hit by a car. There
was no collision. Your job is not to do their job, their burden
entirely. It's theirs.
They have to prove this case and their theory
beyond all reasonable doubt and to a moral certainty. And not
only do they not have a theory,
they can't prove one that doesn't exist.
All you need to know the Commonwealth failed. They failed to
provide you with a truthful representation. They failed to prove
the essence of their case that Jon was even hit by a car to begin
with. They failed to prove any intent on the part of Karen Reed
because she had none. They failed to investigate the actual suspect
in this case. They failed to present the lead investigator to
you. They failed to justify the perjured testimony that you heard
discussed in this case. They failed to hold accountable an officer
who came in here and lied to you and claimed false memories so
she could do the right thing to cover for a fellow cop or cops.
They failed to maintain a fair and unbiased and honest investigation.
They failed to present you with the truth.
And this is what you get. An investigation that's riddled with
errors and omissions and
Guys, we need Okay, you need to dig deep. Okay, if you want me
to do we we might do the prosecution. Okay, but we are running
out of time on the stream. We have four minutes left. If we can
hit the eight more subs we need, okay, we'll do the prosecution
as well, which will be I think it's quite long. It's probably
going to be more than an hour of content, but we have four minutes
to get there. You guys got to rush if you guys want to do it.
If not, we can hit it up tomorrow. It's not a problem. Judgment
and conflicted and corrupted from the start. Every part of it.
That is the literal definition of reasonable doubt. How can they
ask you to be morally certain based on this evidence? It's a
tragedy. When the government fails so completely, so catastrophically,
when there are dozens and dozens of points of reasonable doubt
on the table, your duty, your oath, your oath is clear. Your
sworn obligation under the law is to acquit Karen Reed. Not just
because you can, because you must. Justice demands it.
Do not let the Commonwealth get away with this. Don't let them
get away with this. Do not endorse and sanction an investigation
that is broken and corrupted top to bottom. But just as importantly,
do not let Michael Proctor get away with it. And make no mistake
about it, folks. If you convict Karen Reed of anything, if you
convict her of anything, science, the physics, the data, they
lose. But tragically,
Michael Cropper wins.
Remember his texts? Something stinks. Yeah. But serious charges
will be brought on the girl. She's
Could you ever ever say to yourself, "This is justice."
The fact is there was no collision. A car did not oke. So I ask
you, let your voice be heard not in whispers, but in
Let the community feel through your verdict that justice cannot
be bent and that it will not be buried.
Find Karen Reed. Not guilty. Not guilty.
Not guilty.
Thank you.
Wait, did he say it three times or twice? What? He said it three
times, right? Fine. Karen Reed. Not guilty. Not guilty. Not guilty.
Yes. Three times. Let's go.
Not guilty. Not guilty.
Not
That's what I'm talking about, bro. That's what I'm talking about.
Let's go.
John O'keefee was 40. Okay, guys. I'm a bit sleepy. We got a
minute left on the stream. Okay, I think we have just enough
time to hammer out yesterday's
just enough time for this and then we're going to we're going
to end the stream. Okay, and then we could do prosecutions closing
arguments tomorrow or possibly
check out a verdict. If they've got a verdict tomorrow, I might
think about, especially if I'm if I'm kicking around Discord
or something and they get a verdict out tomorrow, I'm probably
going to try to go live. We'll see. Okay, we'll see. We'll see.
We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. Okay,
check it out. All right, Cherry, are you here for this? I don't
even know. Are you ready to go?
Not that I care.
Uh, what? Excuse me? What do you mean? Not that I care.
Yeah, I don't care to do connections right now.
Okay. Well, I'm going to try to get it right at the end here.
Let's try. Let's try. Uh, okay. Flat
Hook hook hook.
Coaster straw garnish and
glass elements of a
Let's go. What a drink is served with
flat, blank,
wooden, and
I'm a real boy.
Expressionless
like a
What is this music? I don't know. There's dramatic classical
music that we were playing for uh some of the Israel Palestine
stuff. Sorry, some of the Israel Iran stuff. Sorry, different
group of Arabs. served this time. Not Arabs, Persians. I sorry
if there's any Iranians listening.
Bus boy trainee.
Nope.
Bus boy train. Ah, ship shape and carbon.
They start with vehicles. Bus train ship car.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Starting with methods of transportation.
Bracket, hook, rod, curtain. Uh these would be
uh window dressings. Elements of window
Hanging items. Perfect.
So easy.
Crushed it. Nailed it. Destroyed it. Obliterated it.
Wow. Okay guys, I'll uh I'll host out and yeah, we'll see you
all tomorrow. Um we have that aerodyite crisp lettuce thing.
We've got the second half of this. We've got what else tomorrow?
I don't know. We'll see. All kinds of stuff. All kinds of stuff
going down.
Uh Really? Maybe. Really? Is alive
and streaming? He is indeed.
Okay. Shooting people over to
relevant.
All relevant. There they go. Here we go. Over to Really. Talk
to you guys later. Have a good night. Bye-bye.
Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Good night. Goodbye.